and we are live welcome back guys to the uh i am
not a gm tournament and can also say welcome back
to grand master robert hess who's going to be
joining me again for the commentary welcome buddy
hey i appreciate it i'm glad to be back i should
have worn a suit again so people would be confused
which event we're covering today yeah i i
noticed that you look a lot more fancy and
formal when you're commentating the tata but
you know we got our dress down uh sweaters and
t-shirts for i am not a g it's how you know i'm
being at my most serious is when i'm dressed down
that's when i'm sharpest so just so you know
everybody that this is what i take seriously i
love this event in a month i had a great time
watching you and james commentate yesterday
yeah it was a lot of fun and that was just
one of the matches uh very enjoyable to
commentate but they really all have been let's
remind people of the format for this event of
course we have the the main bracket single
elimination so you know you lose you go home
there's gonna be five plus one blitz three plus
one blitz and 25 minutes of one plus one bullet
chest so you get all time controls all formats
for this and of course the winner advances to the
next round which we've seen so far and they're
advancing to the next round and competing for
even more money robert i mean it's not too shabby
ten thousand dollar total prize fund um you know
as an i am i would say that's that's not too bad
to be competing for oh of course not they also
love it you know they have so much fun even when
they're as nervous as teddy coleman was yesterday
they enjoyed the experience of getting to play
some serious competition that is in just the
spirit of having some good chess and a good
time yeah absolutely so more more money at
stake the more points you collect and here is
the bracket we we saw that match that robert
was just mentioning yesterday uh teddy coleman
did come with the victory against carissa yet
um today we're going to be getting into the match
uh kostya kavitsky you can see in sort of the top
left of the screen there against tanya saktev
and that is going to be the focus for today
robert this uh this match is certainly going to
be an exciting one um but i feel like i don't even
need to say that anymore with the you know that's
just what we expect from this tournament um kostya
and tanya what would you have uh what do you have
in store for us you know it's funny we as you
said we don't just speak into the existence and
speaking of speaking tanya she's a very popular
commentator of course she's a very strong player
in her own right and kosia he teaches very often
i know he's on twitch with david pruis and they uh
very instructive lessons that they're often given
well late into the night because they're on the
west coast so i don't know who's the favorite this
is the eight nine match up and i would probably
go with costia i think he's just more experienced
online particularly in bullet but i would not
be surprised at all if tanya takes this match
right yeah that i think you mentioned something
which uh we could see being very pivotal um you
and i were talking pre-show and you had informed
me that tanya actually did not have a good go in
the bullet section now hey could have been because
she was playing levy rosman in the last edition
of this tournament but it could also be because
bullet chess is something that generally favors
someone who's playing online more a lot more
active in that uh you know with the mouse and
um i think that that's got to be kasich kavitsky
in this match so the bullet portion is something
that i'm really going to be looking out for but i
expect him to go toe-to-toe for sure in the blitz
at least yeah and it goes to himself he did get
out to a slow start when he played last year he'll
look to score better in the early stages because
that can be deflating many players myself included
if you lose one game two game you feel like you're
just never going to get that victory when are you
gonna right the ship and there isn't that much
time in this format especially psychologically
yeah yeah i know it's it's important to note that
the uh the times for each format of course that
the bullet has the least amount of time only
25 minutes but it can make such a big impact
because of how quick those games go um what i've
noticed from this format is you and i commentate
a couple five minute games and it's like
halfway done already it's like whoa time flies
yes and those breaks can come at inopportune
moments for certain players they go on
a little bit of a winning streak and there's
a break so that the players can go study the
opening line and fix their mistakes and
that is a very important storyline as well
yeah yeah the the being adaptive i think is
really important in these matches and i don't
know if it's something that's true or not but i
feel like the more adaptive player or the less
stubborn player tends to do really well in these
matches i wonder if i could get a stat on that to
back it up but i feel like that's the case yeah
and karissa i think she played better overall
than teddy i think he would admit that as well
and she was switching her openings up but that
i would agree with you by and large you'll see
that the players who are able to play c4 or play
d4 e4 they can switch it up it causes confusion
for players what are you expecting from me and
well the games are off and we have a qgd right now
quiet line to start with these players i feel like
both of them they go for very principled chess
and less so for speculative sacrifices definitely
i was going to say something very similar as
soon as i saw this opening it almost jogged my
memory oh yeah that's right these guys played
very very principal chess a lot of main lines
i don't know about the the theory being so in
depth but what i would guess is that costia
is definitely going to be on top of things that
sort of happens when you're in that coaching
mentality you sort of have to be up to date on
the latest and greatest in in theory in a bunch
of random different openings because you're not
just studying and preparing for yourself anymore
you might have a bunch of different students
that play all sorts of different openings so
you get that general sense of preparation yeah
and that's really important and tanya does a
lot of commentary and as someone who does such
you don't really study at least not for your
uh shows and for your work you're not studying
the openings so deeply you see them very often
and then in some to some extent you could
be like well the top player is doing this
this is good right like if i see levon aronian
do something i'm like well that's probably a good
decision but it doesn't get you to the fundamental
understanding of why things are happening and here
tanya's spending her time after c takes d5 she's
probably considering do i take knight takes d5 or
throw in the c takes d4 move which she has
done and when i look at this position i'm
on that king on e1 can i somehow just pin this
knight with a quick queen a5 bishop b4 or do i
have to spend the time reacting to this pawn on
d5 well uh now that i see queen takes d4 i'm less
i feel less confident in the bishop before stuff
but um i think i could just play e takes d i'd
be a little more tempted by ed5 um just to get
knight c6 with tempo after seeing queen d4 but
um knight takes d5 and the reason i wasn't
liking this was i thought knight takes and
bishop b2 was like kind of kind of just a nice
quick way to get all the pieces to where exactly
where you want them right and if all the pieces
start getting traded off here where let's say
you know knight takes d5 e takes d5 for black the
idea is bishop f6 winning that rook on the corner
as you point out bishop b2 it forces black's hand
to play bishop f6 but these trades tend to help
white and the reason why is when even isolated
pawn which the pawn d5 is you want to blockade
that pawn so at the end of all of this white would
like a knight or a rook to land on the d4 square
and that pawn on d5 is a permanent target yeah
and uh i would say it just feels like a very very
small edge to to costia here but not definitely
not a big deal i mean there there's so many
you know theoretical positions where you have
that isolated pawn and you just get the knight to
bring the bishop to f5 to e4 and just sort of sit
there attacking the knight putting pressure on g2
and you know tanya is not going to be too upset
with this but um vice versa i'd say koci has got
to be satisfied with what looks like a comfortable
edge to start off this match and just one of these
positions where you feel like you have no risk
from the white side your position is better
your opponent has the worst pawn structure you can
quickly castle king side in the next few moves so
i would kind of dream of having these type of
position especially in a blitz game i think
white's moves are very easy to make and we already
see in a minute advantage in the clock for costia
yeah bishop g4 so again you could always throw
in just bishop e2 nice and simple getting castled
um that would be my my thought without um
looking into the position too much if you
wanted to to maybe calculate something else like
bishop takes and play knight d4 it would be my
other suggestion but i think this is just simple
solid and you know get the king out of the middle
bring the rooks to c and d files and this looks
like a very comfortable easy play for white and i
don't think tanya is comfortable at all from the
black side she's really burning some clock here
it's an extra minute and you know if it keeps
staying at this pace she'll have very little time
to figure out the nuances and you need to play d4
at some point for black that's what you're like
want to do you don't want to passively defend can
i push this pawn to d4 but the big problem is well
first b4 i just okay cozy goes to trade queens
but i think even b4 there to keep the queens on
could have been good but uh it's very difficult
for black to get this move to work and you can
just take back on d2 with the king put a rook on
d1 put a work on c1 and it's going to be a really
uphill battle for tonya to try to hold this
position yeah and the annoying thing is like
after king takes d2 knight c6 if even if you
play bishop takes f3 and d4 and it somehow
works white can't always play something like
e4 and it's it's never clear if that pawn on d4
is actually a good pawn or not you know it's a
pass spawn but could also just be overextended so
i think costia like he's doing exactly what
you want to do in a match like this you get an
easy position you don't have to worry about the
clock um and i think he's just gonna test this
style for game one and see where it gets them
absolutely and the king of the center that's
a good thing we're in an end game the king on
d2 will slide back to e1 to make the rook look
better on the d file but the point is that the
king is happy to be in the center you have great
lines for rook d1 and c1 and actually taking to
mind what you were saying where if black plays d4
white can just play pawn e4 maybe you
don't even need to move your king just yet
and so perhaps costia will do something else and
actually knight d4 could be a nice tactical move
in this position because efficient e2 king e2 and
you're ready to blockade and attack this d5 bomb
yeah knight d4 looks like a nice way to start um
also even if h3 bishop takes f3 happens followed
by d4 i mean even something like bishop takes c6
and that slight slight imbalance of having that
pawn there in a rook end game like sometimes that
alone can be enough coupled with the fact that
that king is so much more active than the black
king and it's it's getting towards an end game
right and i think you're right just bishop
takes c6 here and yeah i actually think that
black is in big trouble it's even material but the
quality of the pieces certainly favors white and
it's because of this king it's going to be very
active it's centralized and you would like to go
and attack these queen side pawns so bishop takes
c6 would be my move i probably and there it goes
and does black already have to start thinking
well am i going to go down a pawn in a rook end
game and try to hold that because i'm not sure you
keep both queenside pawns considering their split
right uh i guess i would probably take as
opposed to letting the king decide to go
to c3 or e3 after taking on uh um taking
on c6 and white takes on on here on d4
decides to take yeah this is just this is just
uncomfortable with a minute left uh i mean this
might be even if rolls were reversed and white
had a minute i'd probably still take white but
but this is just not not good enough i think in
in this format no look at this right since the a7
c6 split that and i keep focusing on and look
rook c4 white's king is on e3 black's king is
on g it's she'll have to spend time with king f8
king e7 but rook a4 forces the rook back to d7
then you go rook a6 and then the rook has
to protect both pawns and you play rook
c7 that allows the white king to go directly into
d4 and then c5 and because white's king was in the
center he's quicker to the action yeah and there
might be a zuk's one if tanya plays t passively
rook c7 and king d7 holds c6 and holds a7 but that
is the only position that holds c6 and holds a7 so
as soon as as the the turn passes over to costa i
think i think tanya might be in serious trouble so
yeah this this is not not good at all when
you're playing passive in a rook end game
robert that's like the cardinal rule you know
that something's gone wrong yeah this is actually
very instructive technique from kostya i
think everything he's done has had purpose
and it's not like tanya's blundered she's made
no serious mistakes but this is how chess often
is at this high level is you get a position that's
uncomfortable you need to find every last accurate
move otherwise you get here and as you said
one this is going to be a soup swamp in fact
if black has no more pawn moves and you're running
out of them and you're also running out of time
but if you have no more pawn moves you need
to move your rook or your king and your
rope takes a7 check and that's one pawn
the rest will also fall in the near future
yeah there's nothing to do you just put
that rook back on a6 and it's like well
hey nothing's changed now i just played b4 a4
a5 put the rook on b6 like um nothing has has
changed about uh about this pawn now you could
play rook takes c6 but i think rook a7 is d
stronger move and king e6 blocks your own rook so
you can't even get active um just really really
impressive technique from kosia in game one
and tanya's gonna have to revisit that whole
i guess that whole energy that she came with
that game she's gotta play faster and she can't
simplify into these slightly worse positions um
while going down on the clock that might have
been a perfect game from costa i don't think
he made a single inaccurate move there maybe
something slight perhaps h3 wasn't as you know
precisely some other move but from our perspective
on that was as perfect as it gets like a 99 plus
percent game yeah and it's like wow okay so i
think maybe tiny i just need to play a different
opening and of course she doesn't but that's the
thought i get when you're in a blitz match where
the next game starts immediately it's as if your
whole repertoire is wrong because that isolated
pawn is something that kosio is delighted to see
wow we have a sharp game already with h5 by costa
this is how you play against the knight on g3
in these same-ish lines in the king's indian
but among what do you know about this because
it feels very risky as well yeah uh the
the thing is i i think it's accentuated
in in classical chess so in blitz i still think
it's a very reasonable option um even h4 here uh
to bring the knight back yeah and that's that's
what he's gonna do um you could at some point
put this pawn down to h3 and the idea is you're
sort of committing to potentially losing that
that pawn in a lot of lines but it's it's it's
the decoy it's it's there that if white wants to
go like bishop g5 bishop takes h4 or if white
wants to go you know h3 g3 and then knight g1
and bishop takes h3 just to win that pawn so many
pieces are going to be taken out of the center and
that's like one two three moves that you hand over
to black so i think that's exactly what khasi is
going for he's looking to make the investment of
the pawn worth it by by moves on the board yeah
he sacrificed the pawn on the queen side where
tiny could have taken on b5 i like her decision
just to blick queen to d2 and now the queen side
will be a bit locked up and that bishop on g7 is
often very powerful in these sharper kings indian
lines at some point in the near future she could
just play bishop h6 trade off what is going to be
black's best hope of an act of peace and i think
that will definitely be in her favor so right now
she has a choice do i keep the position locked up
or do i play with the a3 that comes to mind as
well if your opponent's pawns stick out like a
sore thumb all the way there in b4 i can use my
rook and activate it from where it currently sits
yeah a3 is nice because the queen on d2 is well
positioned but bishop h6 actually using your idea
why not get rid of that bishop i mean black only
has two pieces developed right now and you're
ready to remove both of them yes and you're ready
to go try to checkmate that king if black's not
looking carefully so i do like this decision
by tanya it's really in the flow of the game
here she went knight d5 bishop h6 you're playing
active chess and actually after knight f6 black
has to take with the pawn on f6 but that could go
to black's benefit because with this strong center
for white if you can play f5 but you have a second
pawn behind it to shield your king then this could
help break open the position and white's pieces
the knight e2 the bishop one f1 they're not fully
developed either yeah nice nice thing about uh f6
is that you pretty quickly go rookie f5 and you
just challenge that center black is also going
to probably think about moves like c5 knight c6
put pressure on the dark squares so it feels like
with c5 and f5 there's really good wing counter
play and some nice bayonets to use against the
center for sure and i like that bayonets um and
the thing about playing c4d for e4 that's a dream
come true for most queens pawn players but then
you think about the consequences whenever you have
pawns two squares apart e4 and c4 the square in
between could be your opponents for taking so i
like your idea of playing for c5 knight c6 and if
you can somehow get this knight off the board that
dark square is permanently blacks for the taking
yeah and why not like actually both of those moves
look pretty okay to me c5 and f5 don't know which
one i would actually go for but c5 with knight
c6 into knight d4 has a has a good ring to it
yeah and so i don't think white wants to play d5
because the side that controls the pawn breaks is
off the side with the advantage but if you play
d5 no longer can white break open the position
but black has this f5 move to challenge white's
center so i think that i would either say rook
d1 maybe even castle queen side because that side
of the board doesn't seem like it's opening up yet
but i would probably just try to keep the tension
for at least another turn and use the d file to my
advantage and the the time situation almost speaks
to uh someone who's in exactly the position that
tanya is someone who hasn't played a ton of
uh online chats it's it's just sort of that
that tournament shape it's kind of hard to
describe but if i haven't played an over-the-board
tournament for a year and i just go back and play
even if i've been studying chess in the background
there's that element of hey i just haven't you
know grabbed a 3d piece in a while and i haven't
been under pressure the way that a tournament
might make me feel and uh these matches i think
every player who plays in them the i am not a gm
tournament they always say like man that was more
stressful than i that i thought it was going to be
i think i heard that from levy especially you know
the guys streaming all the time always playing
in front of an audience and when it came to the
match she was just like not ready for that type of
pressure so i think that's what we're seeing from
tanya is she's taking so much time to make moves
that i think she knows like the back of her hand
yeah and i think the biggest thing is not blunders
right when you're rusty at this level it's like
all of a sudden you're going to blunder your queen
it's more so that you're not feeling the flow of
the game as well so you may make a decision uh
slowly when you could have played that move in two
minutes you'd make it in is it classical chess
of course and you make it in ten minutes but
there's also moments where you make a quick move
and you don't understand or don't quite foresee
the repercussions and now you have a target
that your opponent can exploit or weak square
that's your opponents to use and look at this
move by cosine knight d7 he's keeping the position
closed complex and that should bode well for a
person who is up a minute and a half on the clock
and yet i'm sitting here i love tanya's position
i think she's handled this well she took on c5 now
when she ha she controls the d file and after this
move i'm already looking at like queen d6 knight
to d5 trying to march my queen into the position
and go after black here yeah i think uh i think
my instinct is is kind of like just to play a
move like king b1 or bishop e2 eventually get
the knight in queen d6 i guess you could uh play
weirdly brook a6 yeah rook a6 would be doing i
love this move g3 yeah big fan because there are
there are so many positions where you would maybe
never take gh but this is a position where you
can't wait to do that because hey i'll use that
g5 i'll play h5 and you have a second h pawn which
is nice because you're just trying to break open
the file so you go gh4h5 and then black says i'm
not letting you uh take me and put g5 eventually
play h4 with that second pawn and cause problems
for the black king so tanya is playing this really
well kostya trying to drum up some counter play
b3 to my eyes has to be the move i'm not opening
up that rook on a8 to attack my king side the
queen side so i think b3 but b there's a hard
move to play psychologically right you like look
at those dark squares if that queen for black gets
the e5 there could be a quick checkmate but she
plays it she has it's covered and is he gonna
launch something kind of like ludicrous with
f5 and just like rush the queen to to f6 um
you might have to it doesn't well actually f5
i play rook g1 please play queen f6 please play
queen f6 knight h5 check the g pawn is pinned and
richie wants a movie you want to play regardless
so perhaps f5 is you know you're trying to strike
back but you're actually helping white initiate
this attack slow development like kind of such a
weird position both sides haven't fully completed
uh development it seems like but uh we sort of
see what each side wants to do there's h5 and that
f5 move the funny thing about f5 is that the best
move is absolutely rook g1 but apart from rook g1
there's not a lot of other good moves that's true
and rooks you want threats rook takes g6 right now
because 96 is a fork and do you really want to go
play queen takes h4 i'll take your pawn to f5 okay
king h7 there has to be some quick checkmating
attack here h5 comes to mind what are you doing
five e6 oh looks nasty because you can't even take
that one oh that's wonderful and you don't get oh
no oh yeah you deal with this though uh oh and i
think perhaps she was looking at f takes g6 with
check but then her knight on f4 would be hanging
because the rook on the f8 would open up to that
knight so yes oh no yeah this is definitely
oh bishop comes to f5 this is this is bad
wait bishop f5 there's bishop d3 this might
survive for now because you win white's queen
but black's queen is hanging with check on f6 wow
because knight d3 is not a check knight takes f6
with check hopefully smokes whoa but i i do
agree that something felt like it was going
right for kosia and tying down under 20 seconds
but she's seeing some tactics here and that's
she's saving her king by this move bishop to
d3 which looked impossible because under other
circumstances it just loses immediately for white
but that queen on f6 is hanging at the end of the
variation yeah because if this queen moves i mean
you're just pre-moving bishop takes f5 basically
queen c2 and there's no way that that queen can
get back on that dangerous diagonal that's right
and the queen on c2 it even threatens black's
king because if the queen stay on the board
there's h5 and i'm going to go try to win your
g6 pawn but costa simplifies and now it's even
material and in fact black could scoop up a pawn
not yet you don't want to trap your knight or get
a pinned so closely i would consider taking that
by the way i don't know how crazy that is but rook
takes d4 you take on b4 and you get these two pass
pawns it can be hard sometimes to coordinate these
rooks in a position like that yeah i think that's
where you fight your traditional classical chess
instincts where rook takes before you probably
think it's bad but in blitz getting past pawns
is a great thing so i'm with you on that that
would have given white great chances to win and
how i'm looking at this game and seeing how it
might end i think there will be a nice sacrifice
for black and then those pawns on the queen side
will go promote that's one the a3 pawn is is
so close to queening even though it can't move
it's it's such an asset in positions like this
and brook f6 is a big move because that night
tied down to the f7 pawn rook d8 is quite passive
that's true and king e3 played bringing the king
maybe up the board at some point but i don't
think you can get away with it like you your king
probably can't march too far and now costa is able
to oh it doesn't take that h4 pawn yeah he wanted
to like maybe knight e6 is a nice covering move
rook h8 i really like now knight f5 again yeah and
now vert takes h4 comes and the h2 pawn is under
threat it's so interesting because the c5 pawn
is like the easiest pawn in the sense to fall but
now that black is active the a2 pawn is the most
important pawn and yeah look at this rook b2 can't
take that one knight d4 94 knight takes b3 that's
how it's gonna end rook takes f2 and i think b3
oh man and you know talk about foreshadowing
knight v3 may as well even cover the c pawn why
not yes and well how many extra points two of your
pawns is there any chance that white can hold this
i don't think so but maybe there's a way to go
after this b4 pawn the problem is there's a pass
pawn for black and not for white on the other side
of the board that's the issue yeah oh okay knight
d5 that's all you need to make sure you don't drop
that pawn and now even f pawn that's going to run
too yeah knight c6 knight takes b4 is not enough
and i think that'll probably be it for game number
two and that is 2-0 for costa and if we look at
the you know the nature of these games so far
it seems like they sort of have the same pattern
just like a really kind of slow methodical game
but this one had these fireworks at the beginning
that were out of nowhere tactics tactics ablaze
and that's where tina's time consumption is
coming back to haunt her she spent a lot of time
and she was playing good moves but then at that
critical moment she allowed that swift queen f6 95
and that's the biggest difference is in the first
game coz just simplified there were no queens
on the board it was a rook in game where he was
pressing and it was uncomfortable for black in the
second game he retained chances because the queens
remained on the board and he was able to poke some
holes in tanya's queen side and that's where
her king was yep absolutely and here we see a
trompowski actually um d4 bishop g5 characterizes
that opening um it sort of looks like a london
usually when i see players do this robert i'm
i'm kind of expecting them to go c3 followed by
f4 when i see them like not develop the the f or
the uh the g1 knight and it becomes an essentially
an improved stone wall in many regards because in
stonewall with that f4 move if your bishop's on c1
it's behind the pawn structure so it's not acting
with the full scope of a bishop on h4 well that
actually is attacking things right the f6 knight
you can capture at some point and white wants to
play knight f3 and go for an attack on the king
side so i like how this has turned out for costia
yeah and i'm just having flashbacks to chess as a
as a child robert the stonewall is like that was
the being of every kid's existence everyone
has had someone go like knight f3 knight e5
and you you know you take it f takes you just
get checked maybe that's just how it goes
it's true right the first time you see like i'm
doubling your pawns and then white's like yeah
please do that because my pawns get more advanced
and help in the attack and costa has castle that
bishop on b7 that french-like bishop behind your
own pawns here and that's what could have happened
to white's dark square bishop but in this move
order the second move was bishop g5 so that's why
the bishop's outside the chain and one quick thing
amman what do you make of the fact that kosia did
switch his opening yeah that's that's actually
interesting um because usually when something goes
well you're not that interested in switching it
especially when you when you have a game that in
my opinion went as smoothly as the first game did
for him so that's pretty interesting i think he's
just showing already that you know she can't get
too comfortable and one thing that um i don't know
if this is something that is actually true or not
but what i've noticed is that in bullet matches
if you play a different opening people sometimes
forget how bad one opening was at the beginning
and then when you play it again later they
go right back into it without even thinking
so maybe there's some element of that involved
as well yeah that is funny it's true that does
happen you just have we you're trying to focus on
what you usually play and then you forget wait a
second that didn't work out so well the first time
then that punishment is forgotten so the knight is
on e5 this looks very promising for white but i
think many people who are watching say why is it
so promising not a single piece has been traded
white is more active right the knight e5 has
is the farthest piece up the board and the bishop
on d3 is better than the bishop one b7 bishop b7
stairs into your own pawn bishop d3 stares in both
directions and can help launch an attack so i just
feel like pretty much every one of white's minor
pieces with the exception being the knight on d2
perhaps is better than black's counterpart yeah
that's basically it that's a really good summary
there um the the other thing about this pawn on h6
is it always makes a move like f6 or f5 maybe at
some point a little harder to accomplish because
of the weakness on the g6 square and that's one of
the main things you think of you're like seeing
this knight on e5 you're like man get the hell
out of my out of my position f6 is the first
and main move you would think of but it's never
that easy with that pawn on h6 so i'm looking
at this 995 thinking it's very secure piece
i'm also looking at the time advantage and saying
this time advantage is completely reflective of
what robert and i are describing right now
which is a very bad position for tanya and i
i just think that costia almost tricked her in the
opening bishop d3 knight d2 and whenever you see
that that knight still on g1 you get this cheeky
f4 in and i think it's just worked beautifully
yeah now although you can get a bit lackadaisical
with the white pieces here you just make some
moves that look normal and the thing is in this
particular position knight df3 was good but you
may at some point just make a move because you
know it looks good and then you don't think of the
consequence so for example uh maybe you'll just
rush the decision when the best move for white
is c4 that's another idea in this position is that
white can play c form break open more of the board
and i don't think you should do that because it
also helps blocks pieces out but sometimes you
just make these quick moves and then you're not
really thinking about the position as a whole yep
bishop d6 uh i think tiny has had just about
enough of that pin and she might be thinking
about ideas like knight e4 um that's the one thing
about playing knight f3 for white is you sort of
lose that control of the the e4 square and cosy
plays knight takes d7 and i think he's looking to
basically replace that knight on e5 yes and that
will help the queen on d1 because if that knight
recaptures on d7 which you probably i don't say
want to do but you don't want the double pawns on
f7 f6 but if you take on december the knight
the knight comes in e5 as the modern was saying
and the queen comes to h5 and that's
how we launch or the g4 a big attack
yeah and i mean queen d7 i'm less worried about
the double pawns as as black i'm more worried
about like just the tempo that that i'm giving
up so i think maybe take with the king on d7 and
then go king c8 after you've uh moved the rook
or maybe just go the long way well i knew you
were gonna go 95 regardless so i think i just
would have to rush it it's forest it's first um
very reasonable decision in my opinion by by
tanya like she's she's trying to put that knight
on on e4 and she's trying to get that f6 movement
but i i don't think that you can do that because
robert pointed out something important as soon
as the knight moves there's all these queen
g4 h5s to consider and long castle by tanya
wow that is that's committal yes and actually
kosher could have made a clever move and king h1
was trying to anticipate castle king's side so
g4 g5 but if he played queen e2 that would
have stopped the queenside castle because
now he plays it but if i'm black i'm playing c4
i'm closing that side of the board and i'm going
to play rook d to g8 and g5 i need to get some
kind of activity i know i can't do it right yet
but that's what i'm aiming for yep this king
can sort of tuck itself away on a7 but i mean
just look at this time it's not acceptable to be
at 17 seconds this is like crazy down more than
three minutes in a five minute game you i mean
tanya winning this is uh the i mean that's gonna
do wonders for her confidence but it hopefully
won't make her think that this is okay because
this is something that needs to change for
the future that's right and you know she did
capture on b3 her bishop on b7 remains a very poor
piece and that bishop d3 forces some action the a6
bouncing and the b4 i'm just going b4 i'm going
bishop a6 i'm i think i can just go checkmate you
at some point soon you don't really have
help coming up towards the queen side
yeah and look how quickly white's pieces it
looks like they're all focused on the king side
but look how quickly they mobilize bishop d3 rook
fb1 even bishop back to e1 like it's it's kind of
impressive how you can switch from king side
pressure to to queen side pressure and just a
series of moves kosia really is playing an
excellent match thus far he's giving tanya
when he is the white pieces he get he's giving
her almost no play and he is making these really
accurate decisions that continue the pressure and
don't allow her for any kind of counter play so
i love the way he's playing thus far she needs
to figure out a an opening from the black side
that makes her feel more comfortable because
she can't spend this time as we're talking about
i saw her um connection dipped to red just for
a moment there so i'm wondering if that's uh
if that's something to think about but i mean
that was a game that i don't think she had any
chance in it was like plus nine at the end and i
don't even think he had taken material yet like
i don't even think he was that material in the
final position no he wasn't it's just that kind
of game where we've all had those you just make
normal looking moves honestly that's what she did
and all of the coaches had a purpose he gained
space he was able to attack on both sides of
the board and that was a smooth victory so now
she's down three nothing among there's still
plenty of time left in this match and because of
how quickly that game went i feel like we're gonna
get more games overall throughout this co uh this
match as compared to some of the previous ones
yeah and that's that's what's gonna happen
when one of the players um consistently gets
in time trouble is that there's going to be
you know two three minutes um in some games
on kostia's clock that he's just not using uh and
it seems like he always has that advantage whether
or not his position is good because we saw tanya
in game number two she actually had the upper hand
and she was playing some really accurate chess but
the time was still reflective that she was lower
on the clock than ghost yet so it doesn't seem
to have as much to do with the position it's more
like just a general thing that if as we see in the
opening right now just the speed from from kosia
to start this uh this opening off it's just a lot
faster in general right and if tanya were more
informed if she'd been playing more frequently
she'd make a move like d5 this is a blitz game
right you you may look at can i take on e5 should
i leave the pawn where it is i would just play d5
and try to take over some space and i understand
it's not a winning move it's nothing close that
we're still on move nine at this point but you
play the move d5 so that you can serve time
for later in the game and this is what is commonly
said in blitz chess a good move played quickly
is better than the best move played slowly and
right now she is a minute down the clock and
yeah and that's just not acceptable like uh plain
and simple you can't can't think for a minute here
there's lots of decisions uh to make there's lots
of uh okay choices d5 to me uh just also from a uh
the perspective of the move that was just played
makes a lot of sense because usually after d5 the
plane is f5 for black and when i see rookie 8
i know that black probably wants to play rook
back to f8 and then f5 so i would even view
that as uh as a nice a nice reason to play d5
and look at this d takes e5 instead of reacting
to the pawn e5 coaster goes knight g4 and now
i think titus is going to go into another thing
because well that threatens to take this bishop
on e3 and you stack white's pawns there those
are not good the bishop on g7 likes to slice
through the board once this pawn e5 is out of the
way so playing against the king's indian d5 for
white had made sense but now we're getting into a
tactical position where tony can go up two pawns
temporarily by taking on d6 but she's down two
minutes and this is such a hard decision i can't
think of many people who would play e takes d6
and even if they did there's no way they'd do it
quickly um there's other moves like bishop g5 but
it looks like queen b6 has a nice response hitting
f2 hitting b2 and she decides to go queen takes
d6 so look if you want this position i assume
she's playing a good queen takes the eight because
there's no way you can let the queen stay on in
this position right and all things considered this
is a decent position for white i would prefer to
have the black side because white is going to be
up two pawns but those are three in a row i just
give one more let's play connect four let's change
the game we win but these pawns are really poor
two of your extra pawns are the e4 and the e5
pawns and you're stuck defending them i think
it's much easier to play this position for black
but as i say that at a certain moment you start
being like wait a sec i want my material back and
and i don't have another plan besides to win back
the pawns so perhaps tanya with some accurate
moves here she can actually seize an advantage
yep um rook e8 was played not only to get on the
e-file and start targeting some of these pawns but
um also to maybe avoid some trades it's not
necessarily clear uh the white rook can't get into
the seventh rank at all so it's not too important
i think to control that open file at the moment
and knight c5 has been played now one thing that
could go wrong for costia and what you're kind of
hoping for as as tanya is you get some sort of
b4 c5 and you know plant a rook or a knight on
d6 that's the dream um whereas cosi is looking
to meet that with knight d7 and knight takes e5
once you if you if you lose that e5 pawn
in a way that doesn't cost black anything
then that's going to be a big problem but
that's why she went knight d4 she realized
your plan and this is great this is really
great by tanya because the plan was knight
d7 knight takes c5 knight d7 now drops a piece
because of knight takes e6 removing the guard
of this knight on d7 so actually what she
just did there was extremely clever and
very strong yeah and i i think c5 as a follow-up
is is not unreasonable opening up the bishop as
well there's going to be the c6 a6 the b-pawn
is overworked defending both of those things
so that definitely looks uh like something you
could start with king f2 comes to mind as well
you just need to play you're down three minutes
c5 she knows it's a good move she has played it
but she's down nearly three minutes and it was a
good lesson right there though in when you're up
material in this case two pawns sometimes you want
to give back some of that extra material to make
the rest of your position better so she gives up
her e5 pawn to improve her knight to d4 her queen
side pawns start rushing up the board with b4 and
c5 and now she needs to come up with another plan
and she really doesn't have that much time and
this knight wants to go to you know c4 d6 has that
that uh desire but knight d2 i mean d4 just
hangs to start things off and i don't see how
this knight is getting back into the action so
easily i would consider playing knight takes e6
and trying to make a draw they go like an opposite
colored bishop's position to minimize the risk
she's down over uh what three minutes on the clock
right now three and a half minutes and there she
does she needs to get on the scoreboard she needs
to convince herself that she is fully in this
match and knight takes e6 take on d8 rook d1 and
just say i'm not losing this game yeah i i almost
i almost think at this point after rook d1
that that was the best practical decision
as as you've outlined with 30 seconds is kosi
gonna take this well the thing is if he doesn't
we've been talking about rook d7 the whole time
how hasn't been possible now it would be so i
think he did have to do that and now white is
still up a pawn and i would try to play bishop g4
and maybe even take that knight on e6 because in
certain end games and bishop v3 is a similar idea
some end these end games the knight is
actually better than the bishop because yeah oh
oh no so not only did she drop h2 yeah
definitely gonna lose now i feel like
yeah bishop e6 was like a really good really good
opportunity to to maybe not even hold the draw but
even entertain thoughts about winning yeah
the knight is better than the bishop and
this exact type of position because it can
go from color complex to color complex now
there is a dark spot bishop there is the
this h pawn so if you can trade off certain
pieces you can leave black with a dark sword
bishop and the h5 pawn and still make a draw so
i know i say this often people have rolled
their eyes but that is one of the things i'm
considering here as a way to hold but costia is
just making progress with every move it seems like
kind of looked like on the last move like bishop
c3 looked like it won the b pawn i don't know if
that was a moment there white just played king
d3 though so now e4 and c3 are both covered
yes and oh look at this she she regrouped well
knight to c4 and if bishop g3 or something like
that she can consider even playing pawn e5 knight
to d6 and going after the f7 pawn i would go f6
yeah you gotta cover d6 and putting that pawn on
a dark square is definitely not something you'll
be upset with and it's the same thing but in
reverse right we talked about how the knight can
bend the bishop if knight takes e5 f takes e5 that
knight and g5 cannot be dislodged from that square
black's pawn structure is better because what
is the double e pawns and so this is what
kosi would like to see happen please take me on
e5 very impressive uh very impressive defense i
i have to say by by tanya she's very much in this
game and every move that i see happens so far i
feel like she's getting closer and closer to that
draw yes and look at her bishop dominating this
knight an idea has nowhere to go and it had gone
somewhere else like h6 should have put bishop on
e6 so she's playing this pretty much perfectly
and how did this is the same blunder as before
which is why i don't think she noticed it because
i think there was a moment where kelsey didn't
play this move and now now it's probably over
and this is this well it's the third time but
the second different pawn that she didn't realize
was under threat from this bishop the dark side
bishop stole the h2 pawn and then now it went over
the b4 pawn so there was just the time trouble was
influencing her and surprisingly you can probably
take this knight as black although there's like no
no way that that's my first uh consideration i see
what you're saying though because if you trade off
all the minor pieces black wins you pass pawns
on both sides of the board so bishop d4 ed ford
knight to e6 and i wouldn't do that and i don't
think oh he doesn't help because 96 knight f4 is
also an idea after king e3 you can just go knight
f4 and actually when white's pawns can't move
either right d5 you can't be played because c5
pawn hang so he goes and plays g4 and so h3 next
wow very impressive just realizing that d and
e there's can't move at all there's nothing
happening here no and i think you can just go h3
that pawn's trying to i would probably consider
b4 so like if bishop b7 that maybe i have like b3
to sort of sneak by that bishop um but i think h3
just works as well as you said but i like your b4
move because that way you sort of keep that bishop
tied on d5 as you're trying to push your pawns
on both flanks over there but it's hard to give
up that b7 pawn i feel like even if it works it's
not easy but costa he's been calculating very well
bishop takes b7 if he goes h2 you have to e5 and
we're trading off many of the remaining pawns
yeah but c5 falls i guess um still i'm i'm very
suspicious of this conversion well that move is
probably a losing move bishop d5 had to be played
yeah d5 is great keep the king out of e6 and the
good thing about a bishop is it very quickly can
go to the other side of the board so by keeping
the bishop on d5 wow and this is over ready but
the king could have made a decision to go to after
either pawn whichever one you could have tried
to win and that that game was actually really
really impressive by both sides i have to give
full credit to kostya i mean he's got a 4-0 lead
in this match um it is uh it is super impressive
by him but that one move bishop d5 if tanya had
found that it would have been a totally different
game and she might have held that draw robert
yeah but so far so good for costa kavutsiaman
i've been very impressed with his play
it seems like he's sharp today i don't know if
he what he did what he ate for breakfast but
he's in great form right now yeah absolutely and
and we're coming to the uh the first halftime
break of the uh the five minute portion so
hopefully you guys can uh uh stick around
don't go anywhere and when we come back we will
resume this match it's 4-0 for kosi right now
robert and i certainly agree that tanya needs
a bounce back so we'll be right back after this
and welcome back everybody hopefully you didn't
stray too far everyone got a refill of their drink
and uh maybe the person who needed that break the
most robert might have been tanya and it could be
at a very good time because the the score opening
up already 4-0 and from what i've seen uh two main
story lines that that i've noticed is that i
think tanya is actually playing really well
kosia might be playing a little bit better at
the moment but the time situation that tiny's
putting herself in is just not allowing
her giving her an opportunity to succeed
yeah kostya has played exceptionally
accurately i mean we looked during the break
these 99 accurate games and the first one in
particular just has me thinking that i can't
find a better game out there but tony is playing
well that's the thing she's had her chances but
as you're saying this the fact she spends so much
time in the early going it doesn't leave her with
enough left to fight back when her position may
be a bit difficult yeah because let's let's be
clear in that last game she worked from you know
a triple pawn situation and down four minutes
to nearly potentially holding a draw
at the end if she played bishop d5
and that's all to show that you know she
had just a couple more seconds to consider
she might have played bishop b5 instead but
it's a time situation that's really hurting her
and uh you know even players who are the best in
the world at playing with low time you don't want
to be in that situation hey if you if you get low
on time then you're a good enough player to handle
it but you never want to be in that situation yeah
i think part of the issue is that when players
compete in blitz events they're typically three
minutes so perhaps you feel like you have all the
time in the world now you five minutes i can spend
time on move three when i wouldn't do that in a
three minute game so here we go bishop g5 played
she was g6 this time different opening she did not
like what happened in that stone wall i agree with
her decision now we're getting more into a modern
type of setup and will kosher play e4 here which i
think e4 is the most principle move but he prefers
these c3 e3 you know triangle pawn structures yeah
and um i was wondering now that we've seen the
move d5 uh what you know what stops me from maybe
doing it again i mean it is possible here i do
think she's chosen a better setup but i actually
was expecting pawn to d6 from tanya to deal with
that knight on e5 that was being planted there so
that's what i was expecting but we don't see that
from rbc d5 do you think he's gonna go for this f4
still or just more knight f3 see the thing is this
f4 knight f395 it's not quite as impactful because
the bishop on d3 is blunted by this pawn on g6
it still is a plan and it's a reasonable plan
and he goes for it but if i'm tanya i'm not
quite as afraid i would actually be fine castling
kingside but i would also think about moves like
queen b6 can i sort of counter against white setup
this pawn on e3 feels a bit loose maybe i'll have
a timely knight g4 as well and that's what i'm
trying to grasp right now like can i play knight
g4 right now and maybe even sacrifice my knight
on the e3 square so knight g4 and let's say queen
e2 feels like the the way to meet that and then
some sort of like id3 cd4 and you know all the
pieces get active that's what i'm looking at and
yeah she takes first but that actually helps clear
the square on e3 i wanted to sacrifice as a king
in the center not my pieces i always do this but
still that's what i was looking for and do you
think um okay so queen there and that's actually
a move that has some intentions if you castle h6
hits that bishop which is guarding the the f pawn
you know if you move away all of a sudden
maybe queen takes f4 it becomes a move there
yeah and while 95 says no f4 pawn for you i'm
just going to block your queen's path you don't
really want to take on e5 because then the pawn
will capture but this is different if you can
quickly play f6 for black you know move your
knight away from the f6 square you challenge
white's center so i would even consider the move
knight takes e5 followed by but if you take with
the f on knight g4 isn't threatening anything no
i was trying to quickly well actually maybe still
works i'll go knight g4 and even if you attack
me i'll play f6 it's probably still still okay
because you're saying like if h3 you could just
go f6 right yeah so 98 very similar idea and
i'm actually a fan of 98 if if you want to choose
a less committal uh decision because the knight g4
taking a knight g4 as robert with f6 looks like
if you're miscalculating maybe things get scary
but 98 looks like hey f6 is coming next move and i
love this reroute knight d6 with bishop f5 and the
the light squares come under your control i think
tanya has handled this position uh a lot better
and also if you check the clock i think it's
reflective of that and i'm trying to think which
impacts the other is she playing more quickly
because she's getting into the rhythm of the match
or you know what's the order here of why the the
moves are good versus the clock situation but
still she clearly thought about it she played g6
on the second move to make sure that the stonewall
attack wouldn't be so powerful and now with f6
you have to go knight takes c6 and i'm wondering
if i can go ahead and take your bishop on g5
and get the two bishops but that's also a big
choice that you have to think long and hard about
before you just do yeah takes takes on g5 i guess
um you're bringing the knight back to
e5 there or something maybe knight b4
yeah the d5 pawn's a little bit soft there so hmm
i still feel like f6 is right now for knight takes
e6 you can just take back on c6 that yeah yeah
b takes i think you can still continue then with
knight d6 and bishop f5 i get the impression once
these light square bishops trade with a knight on
d6 that that black's just doing well no matter
how the position looks like kick things out with
f6 knight d6 even right now um i'm liking tiny's
position but i'm not liking the minute she just
spent on this move i shouldn't have complimented
her time robert it's my fault no i just
one of these days where every single move you're
overthinking and she does in fact put 96 and i've
seen the evaluation bar it changes pretty much
nothing the engine agrees so she spent a minute 23
seconds she could have played that in 23 seconds
or even less yeah and let's be clear when she
played 98 uh she knows and we know she knows that
knight d6 was her plan uh from from minute one as
soon as uh knight e8 was played but it was more
just the overthinking and hey uh you know white's
actually allowed me to play f6 is this something
i should be going for um whereas knight d6 her
original plan turns out to be the one she goes
for it turns out to be a great move by the engine
yes and it's the big difference of let's say
commentating and playing i always say this when
i'm commenting i can make all these suggestions
and then if it's bad nothing happened i just don't
say oh this is why it's bad and i take it back in
a game you're double triple checking because if
that move is bad you lose the game and so exactly
she plays knight d6 she probably was thinking was
f6 possible there spent a bunch of time doing
that and now f6 again is possible because you
give up d5 with check but you can play pawn e6
stopping the check attacking the queen that takes
your pawn now the knight on e5 and bishop and g5
are hanging so i think f6 is a forcing move but a
good move from black's point of view i think it's
a great move and i don't think it's that hard
because like after queen d5 e6 there's not much
else to calculate there's just a whole bunch of
hanging pieces um and i imagine after king h8 it's
technically probably also still playable because
like things are still hanging there so point being
i think f6 should be on her radar from last move
and queen f3 shouldn't change that now imagine
that she doesn't play f6 i'm trying to wonder
what move she's going to play and i was about to
say i think she's going to consider e6 to defend
that but i think that's definitely the wrong
idea that bishop wanted to get to f5 so badly
yeah this is going to be a problem for black
because the bishop is now blockaded by its
own pawn queen h3 taking advantage of black's
last move you played e6 your bishop no longer
hits across the diagonal i play queen h3 why
is queen h3 good maybe i'll play bishop h6
and maybe i'll bring my rook up to f3 so first
my queen then my rook and black doesn't have
too many defenders on the king side so she needs
to figure out can i play f6 now but after f6 now
there's knight takes g6 as a possibility going for
like a quick checkmate against that kingdom yeah
knight g6 looks very dangerous after f6 um there's
so many things to think about there there's like
e5s in the position but no she's not going to bite
on any of those i mean this rook can swing over
to the middle g4 always keeps a knight out of f5
so i don't think cosia's ever worried about that
right maybe knight g4 ideas yeah i like knight
g4 because now f6 really is a threat at long last
f6 will be the move played if tanya had a
free move so knight g4 doesn't prevent f6
from being played but it doesn't allow
block to fork the minor pieces either
yep definitely i think bishop h6 also makes
some sense i mean that's eventually after f6
after knight g4 you would probably go bishop h6
anyway so i think bishop h6 is still reasonable
as well and played so you called it and i think f6
you know it doesn't change much here if you oh i
okay i guess f6 now knight f5 comes with tempo so
you can play this move order but i something about
taking on h6 always worries let's play f6 robert
and i are cheering for f6 for so long i think
defensively you need that move and i'm very happy
to see it on the board so am i and i wonder if
this knight has to move you mentioned the knight
comes f5 white can play g4 can costa just play g4
here and have the position completely open up and
how how crazy it's like g4 you take here and you
can just take back f takes e5 and he decides to go
bishop takes and wow i'm looking at this position
robert and i'm seeing e takes f5 i'm saying hey
that's my e4 square and you know what that's also
my e5 square that's not something you get to say
every time when you play against these um i guess
these stonewall setups and she decided to say with
the knight i liked your decision to take with the
pawn either pawn aussie even g takes f5 at least
possible but she takes the knight and her position
is still looking pretty good her clock is not
though she's 23 seconds to her opponent's minute
and a half and it's not exactly clear what black's
plan is going to be are you going to go for
a5 b5 b4 is the threat bishop b5 right now to pin
this knight on d3 but if you move that bishop e6
becomes a bit more tender is white going to play
g4 and g5 because the dark squares should come
under white's control because it's a light square
bishop against some knight so i would actually try
for g4 and if i can make it work then g5 but i
understand that black lost with an e5 tactics
i'm not calculating that right now too much yeah
i i would go for instinctively i would go for
something like g4 maybe move the queen to like g3
or g2 and then try to go for g5 but um i'm keeping
in mind that you know even if that happens and
e5 isn't a tactic if black plays like f5 and 94
that's also fairly reasonable um okay queen
g3 played so i think g5 is on the horizon here
tough to deal with with only 18 seconds on the
clock and bishop c6 i think bishop b5 would have
been my choice but she's trying to play 94 so she
has clear purpose to her moves and if 94 happens
well i can get my pawn on e4 play f5 and
try to improve my position this manner
yeah no totally understand here
so i would play some sort of b6
a5 moves to to take some night squares away but
i'm on this bishop on c6 if that knight gets a
dark square it should be five yes bishop b5 is
begging to be played get it the hell out of there
i think you could play it next move that
night doesn't really have any we're good
because f4 is hanging yes and bishop b5 now go
after the knight you are going to be struggle in
the long term if you do not take this knight a5 i
understand it it's a good move but we're screaming
for bishop b5 and oh no like bishop c8 i don't
know what it does it was is if the point is to
go bishop a6 then that could have been done a long
time ago but look at this then i found out this is
this is bad now i think it's just lost even
though black's not down a single piece white has
no threats right now but the knight can come in g4
to f6 simon queen h4 king up to g3 just to protect
the f4 pawn and bring some rooks to the h file
i think he's gonna go like king g2 maybe rook f2
and there goes 96 check wins not h6 wins the
rook but he knows that it wins the rope no matter
what it's actually just trapped he doesn't even
want the rook honestly okay i i like the moves
uh from tania she knows she's losing the
rook there's nothing she can do about it
right um c4 there's queens one i'm looking for
one yeah rick f1 was strong there that's okay
so how does this black get in this if that
bishop sneaks in anywhere here then it
could be really good for her two seconds one
second we need to move wow point four left
yeah if that bishop could someone get to e4
block his chances but no chances oh my goodness
i feel i feel like these positions are like
she right when we uh we feel like she's back
in the game i i take a look at the clock and i'm
like oh no there's like 15 seconds left because
she defends these positions so well but the clock
she's not putting herself in a position to succeed
no she's not and she has played some very good
games she was playing a very good game that
one and then she didn't have time left to figure
out how to proceed the bishop didn't get out the
knight dominated the dark squares so she needed
to play move like bishop to b5 and it's just clear
that the match is getting to her at this point
she's down five nothing she needs one game just
one victory as soon as she gets that victory i
think things can fall into place but we're already
getting to the point where it could be not too
little too late there's so much time left in the
match including this five minute portion but you
know you it doesn't feel good to start down half
uh no it definitely doesn't and we're also seeing
the most amount of games that i've seen at least
in the five-minute portion i you you mentioned
this right at the start of the match was like
uh based on the time that tanya is is uh spending
on her moves uh kosia is finishing a lot of these
games with multi minutes on the clock and so we're
actually getting more volume of games in this five
minute portion and this line robert i i hate this
line i play the the sameish i dislike this with
the passion black goes e5 and then goes like d5
and just says hey you know what you calculate it
don't don't tell me to do a mon where are your
co-commentators here but yes that is the theme
of this position black's play is in the spirit
gambit and stuff like that where you lose a pawn
sacrifice it and then you have all these open
lines and whether that's using the b file opening
up the center like it's an e5 d5 you need to
be so precise here from timer's perspective
to just avoid losing in the next 10 moves because
your king's in the center and here i think you
can just be knight c5 three knight to b3 the acon
is pinned thanks to the fact that black does not
have an a pawn so very quickly black's pieces are
coming into play and white is several tempi down
in development exactly um you know white has
the dream of this position where it's like takes
knight takes other knight to c3 bishop c4 it's
a beautiful grip on the light squares especially
because this pin is not something you can get rid
of very easily h6 can always be potentially taken
um reminds me of these like positions where you
go h6 bishop h6 knight takes e4 with the tactic
queen h4 winning the bishop on h6 and suddenly all
the dark squares fall so maybe h6 can be played
actually yeah it's it's those kind of lines are
very interesting and of course you end up taking
d5 the one thing i'll say is now they're both feel
like they're in neutral territory where they're
out of the opening stage they have about the same
amount of time kosia is not and he does play h6
so i think i think you almost have to
take and just play on the light squares
yeah that makes sense and it's in the spirit
of a sicilian except for the fact that white
is already up a pawn so i think you like you said
take on f6 knight c3 and so on but if you did this
this is the wrong move order you should have
left the knight on d5 and taking f6 with the
bishop right away and just went knight e2 to c3
and so on and the problem here is after bishop
f6 bishop f6 knight c3 black gets to play bishop
e6 and white doesn't have bishop c4 as a follow-up
so it's maybe not the most consequential thing
it's just a point of frustration and i think
knight f6 looks like a move played by someone
who maybe just overlooked uh bishop h6 knight
e4 and noticed it later because in hindsight i'm
sure she would prefer to play bishop takes f6
first and then the bishop e3 it's going to be
d5 and black is doing very very well here yes
and you can even sacrifice the exchange
i'm sure and go for the initiative but
you can play rookie and keep it simple if
you don't want to drop some material but
yeah i think i think that d e is it's almost
not even a sacrifice because it's damn near like
theory or something like that if if white
does this in general against d5 in this line
you just always sacrifice it so that's one of
those sacrifices almost like you're telling
a grunfeld player to sacrifice the exchange
it's like okay i was going to do that anyway
yeah it is just like that the sicilians sacked
that rook on c3 for a knight absolutely and here
look at this just take bishop b7 black's pieces
have all these natural scores to work with and
white's king will not find shelter no matter if
it stays in the center or goes in either direction
that king is going to be in trouble yeah and just
such a solid king position for cosia so it's it's
you know knight h5 knight uh f4 bishop b7 bishop
e6 are the first ideas to come to mind queen c5 is
a nice centralizing move which kind of makes white
think twice about castling in either direction
yeah this is much easier for black to play but
you just mentioned all these moves perhaps being
spoiled for choice causes some paralysis of like
wait i i which one is the most precise because
at the end of the day chess players especially
these strong players here they want the truth
of the position they don't want to just you
know make these split-second decisions that may
not be accurate i think kosher wants to find the
perfect move at this point and now he's thinking
he's about to be even on the clock does he put
his rook on d8 or is it better to play queen to
c5 and if i play queen c5 well why play queen f2
and you start questioning can i trade queens or
must i keep them on the board because i'm down in
exchange all these questions swirl in your mind
it costs you time on the clock and for
costia he has a great position but in
the back your head is i'm down some material
so i actually need to make sure that i'm not
dilly dallying and allowing my opponent
to take over an open file for example
and can we talk about tanya's first lead on the
clock in the entire match i don't care what the
position is this is a good sign tanya needs to
be hopefully she's thinking on kosi's clock not
kostya available look at that tanya spent 13
seconds in previous games she would have spent
45 seconds a minute on that move castle she
is making sure that she will have enough time
to think after this because castle is not losing
right away it could get her into some difficulties
maybe this pawn for black is going to e3 next but
at least she has time to figure out the next stage
of the game yeah that's a great point that's just
blitz for you you can't calculate every possible
repercussion after e4 she's not sitting there
wondering you know what happens if it gets to
e3 long term is that good or bad she just canceled
13 seconds that's a great decision king h1 not uh
not going to play queen f2 and walk into e3 so
now e3 and she's gonna have to to think just do
i want to blockade with the queen run into bishop
a6 or just queen c2 here right and for the record
i don't really enjoy white's position but if you
play queen c2 and just keep playing quickly you
will have better chances to survive this queen c2
and knight d5 looks strong the knights seem to pin
to the queen on c2 so it's not necessarily a fun
position to play but if you have time left you can
spot tactics f4 yeah i like because i was gonna i
was gonna say f4 maybe after knight d5 so that's
why i thought of f4 here as well just as an answer
to knight f4 because knight f4 looks so annoying
and she plays it queen takes g2 and she could
actually maybe counter against the black king all
of a sudden if a timely f5 for white happens that
could spell some trouble for the king on june i
would not play that move it allows black by g5 and
take over the f4 square but you want to keep f5 in
your mind because sometimes you play f5 and after
g5 play f6 right you just like give away that pawn
to try to open up files for your rook yeah and
queen d5 look at the speed from tony i i just
think the last 10 moves from her um have been
fantastic just in terms of how quickly you want
to get these moves out yes and the pichu phone is
hanging so that's a bit of an issue rook a b one
not exactly the move you want to play black like
e2 the f4 pawn is hanging and feels uncomfortable
uh perhaps you do play f5 f6 and shoot
queen e4 which probably is also a good move
so yeah takes takes um takes on b2 you don't
even really calculate that you just say look
i've got an outside pass bond there and queens
are off the board that's that's probably a good
thing and so costa he doesn't want to trade
queens queen h4 is a natural attacking move
but it's easy to meet right quinnish four the
queen goes maybe go back to uh oh there's queen
g2 that's 1924. but knight f4 happens and but
then you play queen f3 perhaps and you win the e
but the rook takes p ah so many tactics i think
you can play queen g2 and maybe you have to play
queen g2 yeah yeah so um is there rook takes b2
in any way i'm trying to like go super aggressive
but probably it's just super unnecessary knight
f4 looks solid and good and there we go oh that's
a good move yes that's a good move by the way
i think the position has to be good for black
though you just trade queens but like knight d3
and the b2 bombs under attack fisherman g7 is uh
hitting the knight and see the reason that pawn
can move but a4 just go for it right just just go
this is you can't waste time trying to defend this
a4 i don't know knight takes uh b2 maybe knight e2
plant your knight in front of the pawn and go like
rook a2 and just close your eyes and go to the
promised land a8 that's that's what you have to
try for and with bullet experience you play a4 and
hope that it works out it's probably losing maybe
not regardless but you're gonna be in trouble
no matter what and it could be a losing move
but at a certain point you just have to go with
it and i like work f3 though yep yeah rook
f3 i will say the reason that i don't like
it is because time's getting low and it looks
like a move that needs some justification it's
going to discoordinate white's pieces a little
bit and if she can find the right calculation
i'm all for it all for it so 92 that's the
move i would play quickly right now just
get that bishop and then the bishop has to make a
decision do i worry about the b2 pawn or keep e3
defended and if i keep e3 defense move now
i have two pass pawns on the queen side so
this is improving for her she's still 20
seconds so she's keeping a better pace
yeah this is fantastic so bishop a7 i think he
might just like chuck it all the way back there's
no way he wants to give up that e pawn no and i
guess the another annoying thing is rook d1 is not
possible because there's knight f2 checks with b3
to start with so c8 is what i would go for there's
still no rook to d1 said he brings his back to
f1 ooh okay rook a6 maybe she wants yes she's
probably gonna play rook a6 where's that bishop
going yep and there could be a mate though if rook
d2 rook takes e2 knight of three that's checkmate
that's a networking one no knight f3 oh no
oh okay but knife three can't really be stopped
yeah knight f3 is nasty okay gotta take that
you have to take it you know knight f3 here we
go there ambrook d1 yeah and then bishop f2 and
you're winning the rook here coaster man
this guy is just on fire he's on fire he's
on fire because this was like one of tonya's
best games in my opinion she she handled
uh things while on the clock and on the board
and what did it come down to just a blunder like
one move at the end um costa is just like if
i'm trying to think of chances where it's like
you could have won the game against him i can't
think of any i can think of chances where he
could have played a better move and maybe put
him under more pressure maybe hope he would have
blundered but robert i'm not seeing any games or
any moments where kosei was just lost on the board
or anything close to it so far and i think that he
deserves all the credit of course we keep talking
about time management and how time tonya's
struggling to keep an edge on the clock it's
been very rare but kosia has been playing accurate
chess it's not like he's winning games where
he's minus five or he's down at full rook and then
he went on time no all the games he is fighting
and he's been better in a bunch of them so i
think that kosia has played an excellent match
at this point it is six nothing tanya she needs to
find the right play we're back i'm on to game one
right you said you don't go back to something
for a while but here we are back to game one
and now time has to figure out do i play c5 again
this is exactly what i was talking about because
she's like she's like c5 oh wait i lost that
game really badly and that was no not fun at all
and she's thinking damn i think i need to play
another move here and she's going to find one but
it's going to take her a minute that's already
worth it after coast yeah and coach is still in
his general preparation he's in that framework
of what he was looking for in the opening
now even though you don't have the isolated pawn
right now it's going to be difficult for black
to get the move c5 in as is often the case though
tony's doing the right thing she's playing quickly
just just take with the queen on d5 play for c5
that's what i would do here queen d5 queen h5 if
bishop c4 it looks like and then just c5 knight
c6 rooks to the the two open and semi-open files
yes and she's thinking do not take with the pawn
and diva there we go please don't there we go i
like this i like this yeah pawn takes d5 would
have been getting her into the exact type of
position she does not want to play and maybe she's
fine playing that in classical chess but with so
little time on your clock you don't want that
position so come on she is doing five o'clock
i like black's position here i think that white's
pawn pushes could backfire whenever you push upon
some squares you're previously defending become
weaker so queen h5 just go yeah queen h5 um it's
not that you necessarily want to play bishop takes
f3 but you're just setting things up i mean queen
g6 looks super normal hitting uh g2 getting
out of this uh this pin but this move i'm not
a fan of it's like white just played bishop e2
for free i'm just gonna back up a couple moves
and just show like if white plays bishop e2 here
it's black's turn and if i fast forward to the
game it's actually white's turn in the exact same
position so uh kostya whether it looked like it or
not he got the upper hand there he certainly did
and now he's making use of that fact because he's
rooks in c1 hitting the c7 pawn and if you play c5
now the position opens up and you start thinking
about whose pieces are better that bishop on b2 is
thrilled to see the move c5 so yeah that was just
an unfortunate decision by tanya i don't think
she should play c5 yet she's playing rook a to c8
it's not easy she does do that it's not easy
for white to stop c5 so you just want to time it
correctly yeah even if b4 i mean the the opening
of an extra file is not going to be too disastrous
for either player really so including b4 into the
c5 calculations i don't think matters too much
that's right and opening the c file too early
there was a rook on c1 that would have been
the first rook to take over the file so now she's
just preempting it she's making sure that when the
file does indeed open she is rooked to counter
white's rook on c1 and the main difference i see
in the position so far is that minute that she had
to spend to come up with b6 right at the start of
the game funny enough um both positions i would
take either side here which is kind of the sign
of probably an equal position more or less the
queen always has h5 if he gets attacked i think
c5 here is very reasonable um rook d8 and 84 all
come to mind but the thing is you just got to move
we've been saying this a lot i would think about
rook d8 like you said c5 maybe bishop d6 knight e4
all these moves are possible just just pick
one just go gotta pick one it's gonna be
another minute think here nearly um for tanya
she started around three minutes and she's
closing in on two minutes a5 again good move uh
tanya has not been short on good moves this match
robert she has not made uh two serious uh blunders
usually they're like they're one move and it might
be at the end of the game in time pressure but
when tanya thinks she comes up with good moves but
the problem is i don't think she needs all that
time to play that good move she needs to trust
herself more and she can play that same move you
know two three four five times faster that's right
and another good move here that i'm seeing is made
bishop d6 because i'm going for a cheapo i'm just
going to go knight g4 and take your h2 pawn and
then meet you with my bishops across the board
that's kind of thematic in a sense when you have
a control of a long diagonal you want to go for
an attack so i'm playing bishop d6 to free up my
rook from c8 and i can play c6 later if i want but
i'm just trying to attack the white king yep uh c6
also makes a lot of sense after a5 so i feel like
c6 bishop d6 are the first two moves that come
to mind even c5 if you want to like just force
the issue with with ampassa so c pawn or bishop
here is what i'm thinking if if rook d8 comes
i'm a little bit concerned about you know like
bishop c4 95 kind of stuff and and white taking
over that c6 square and down two approaching two
and a half minutes robert it's just not going to
cut it against costa here bishop d6 another good
move but too much time spent a full minute plus
coming up with that move and she saw that
instantly right there's no doubt and that's what
amanda keeps saying is she's playing good moves
she's making good decisions she's just double
and triple checking in times when she shouldn't do
that she's being a perfectionist queen h5 just go
there we go all right now there's a threat there's
a big threat of bishop f3 so 95 makes sense and
they play queen g5 you don't want trade queens
you know that's a bad end game for you uh or queen
in this middle game i say play queen g5 keep the
queens on the board because f3 there's queen e3 f4
well hello you're actually getting mated
there so there's not a good answer g3 i think
everyone can understand tanya needs no reminder
that that bishop is gorgeous on that long diagonal
after g3 so queen g5 i mean tonya knows it's the
automatic move here we just need to see it quicker
yes and she's thinking here the thing is you
look at this position if you oh i would say
if you trade queens you know you're just worse
and then she goes ahead and trades queens so
i feel like amanda she just doesn't have the like
it's not the feel of the position but it's almost
like she doesn't believe in her the what she's
intuiting from the position and so she keeps
thinking for too long and making the decision
that she would never make in a classical game
yep i think i think that goes back to just sort
of tournament shape game shape um which was
that thing that i was trying to describe at the
beginning but i was having a hard time doing so
um it's really hard to describe just being out of
shape and it's like oh no don't worry you've been
studying whatever you know your lines um tiny is
obviously very immersed in chess in her everyday
life but it's uh it's the the theory uh being
able to play the beginning moves of the game
way quicker than your opponent jump out to that
minute minute and a half edge which kocia has
protected the entire match that's true and i think
for those of our viewers in the audience who are
made newer to chess or not so experienced you look
at this position say wait why is white better here
why is double pawns it doesn't seem that bad for
black but bishops just control so much of the
board and this pawn e5 while it is doubled it's
going to help the rook lift into the d6 square
and then if that rook you can envision that
work on d6 please take me there i would love
it for you to capture me there and if not that
b6 pawn now is a target i'll put my bishop on d4
and then play pawn to e4 and directly go after
that i think you just do that right now rook c8
should be four pawn four and in any order yeah
bishop d4 pawn e4 uh bishop c6 b5 bishop b6 and
robert was just tarping on those bishops
and now you get to see them in action
and the you know bishops work into their to their
maximum effect uh robert it's a it's a beautiful
thing except if you're tanya in this position but
otherwise it's a beautiful thing that's true uh
for those of us who have no nothing invested in
the game the bishops are fantastic and e4 king
e3 king d4 king c5 just don't get four don't allow
knight c6 with the check otherwise this is going
to be quite straightforward uh oh bishop b4 here
is lights out just take that and bring the king
and even right there you saw kosia pre-move bishop
takes e7 that's a sign of somebody who is playing
quite a deal of blitz because sometimes you're
going to make that move regardless but he had that
pre-moved so he's understanding the dynamic he's
has expectations for his opponent's move and he's
finding the right response in advance yeah yeah
and it's now 7-0 and this is going to be the last
uh five minute game most likely in this in this
section as i see just a minute ticking down on
the match clock but to get eight games in the five
minute portion is quite a lot and it speaks to the
fact that most of these games are finishing when
kostya has two minutes three minutes on the clock
um and you know over the course of seven
games to have like two x that's like 14
minutes that's two three extra uh entire games
um yep this is uh this is quite something and and
like i can talk about the time pressure for tanya
over and over again but i want to make sure i'm
giving full credit to costa i think he's actually
playing an incredible match right now so few
blunders robert i'm just like wildly impressed
with the way coast just playing he's made no
blunders at least not that i can recall and he's
playing very accurate brand of chess he's playing
quickly i i would like to ask him when this match
over about his preparation because it does seem
like he thoroughly prepared for it he's done his
research and he's just finding openings that are
good for him they fit his style but here's
this moment again we've seen this position
bishop takes f6 knight takes up stick then knight
e2 to c3 you don't give black the same flexibility
because white's bishop now has the access the
c4 square and so bishop e6 there's a knight in
between those pieces yep exactly bishop takes f6
knight c3 i think is the only other try because
she knows that this stuff is too tricky too
dangerous bishop takes h6 can't go for that um
and knight f6 she tried last time and i don't
think she wants to repeat that although maybe
spending time here i'm trying to think maybe i
don't see anything else besides bishop takes i
guess bishop h4 to keep the pin up but spending
too much time right now or bishop e3 right away
maybe the thing up bishop e3 the knight
takes d5 and if the queen takes you feel
like your queen doesn't really want to be on
d5 but you're right d3 is a move to consider
yeah it definitely doesn't i guess they're i
feel like in those positions there's often a
uh like a very aggressive way to play like
knight b6 bishop e6 queen v6 sack the rook
in the corner you know take on b2 get a very
very aggressive um way to play going because
that that's that's usually how these positions
go and what what a time investment right here
we just need another move and tiny's racking her
brain trying to find something different than what
she did last time um but she's also so attached to
his bishop you can tell um in this opening that's
just a piece you don't want to give up for a night
most of the time and it's good to be skeptical as
a chess player but i would trust kosuya right
i would just say uh h6 i can't capture all the
stuff he's playing this opening fast so i just
need to move she does bring her bishop back to e3
but didn't we see this exact position that we did
earlier and shooting bishop c5 d takes e4 and the
position quickly collapsed for white so i'm not
even suggesting that this position itself well
i was gonna say i don't think it's lost
but this isn't good that's for sure
it's definitely not good and i think at this
point because she's invested now two minutes
on that that thought process and didn't come up
with anything new she's just going for the same
line because okay at least i can repeat these
moves you know the next uh i don't know if kosi
is going to play the same exact way quite possibly
he will but she's looking to just copy your last
moves to get quick moves out yes and this is the
biggest difference between a match like this and
tournaments that you see in rapid chess or
classical chess where in those tournaments
you lose a game you have time to go back say what
did i do wrong how can i improve so i don't get in
trouble again and then you make those adjustments
there's no time to adjust in this format
and so kosia he just says why not i won a great
game uh with this opening and look at this rook v8
we've seen all this before the b two pawns under
attack only black is a dark square bishop that
queen can come to c5 the bishop is going to b7 or
maybe if it wants to go to e6 or h3 if the bishop
doesn't stay on the f1 h3 diagonal for white
the flexibility for black here and the two extra
minutes they speak volumes and look at what a what
a gamesman coast he is i love his decision not
to play the same line because he says look you're
playing into the same bad line i think i know what
you're trying to do you're trying to just repeat
the whole game and maybe improve later on at some
critical moment well i'm just gonna get you out of
you know your theory so to speak or get you out of
that copycat idea from last time i'm just gonna
play rook b8 now you have to think all over again
as if it's a brand new position and you're low on
the clock i'm gonna try to take advantage of that
so i think it's just a just a great decision
and he has five different good looking moves
every single turn he was queen c5 other ideas that
come to my mind include rook to b4 knight to h5
developing the light square bishop to any of
its squares b7 a6 literally f5 right you have
all these choices but he's making his decisions in
10 seconds and that's leading him to kind of win
on the board in addition to the clock so the
knights have betrayed now something has been
clarified bishop a6 you're not castling kingside
you're certainly can't castle queenside so
how do you continue here for what i'm struggling
queen h4 another uh cheeky idea because even queen
f2 you can't just take that clean up these queen
side pawns afterwards and that end game only black
can win as well in addition to queen edition
maybe you'll play bishop f6 bishop h4 and just
go for a checkmate because the king is
stuck in the center you're right that
even without the queens if black can take b2 and
a2 you're winning all the pawns and blacks in good
shape so i mean h4 i mean i'm just grasping at
straws here but maybe h4 um because i feel like
i don't i can't give you that h4 square yourself
well it's too late now rook c3 isn't played so
bishop f6 to h4 seems pretty powerful refreshing
especially because you can use h4 g5 so many
options and the time is reflective of how easy
the position is to play and i think rook c3 was
interested in queen hill which he does play which
i think is a mistake but it's so tempting to give
the immediate check but look what she's done she
missed queen f2 if we do in fact get a trade the
king will land on g3 black will take b2 and a2 i
do don't think though that white should be fine in
that position i understand that black is happy to
have four pawns on two and it's an exchange down
but there aren't too many pawns remaining and the
rooks get active so i think that yeah she can hold
that kind of position i would not trade queens
if i'm closed yet yeah completely agree if that
bishop was like on e6 in that position i think
it'd make a world of difference but being on a6
it's a little you know kind of uh uncoordinated
over there and queen takes f2 makes the position
easier to play and that's what kosia is thinking
about right now i said damn i don't want to make
it that easy to play she's just going to take
her king on g3 double the rooks or whatever like
too too easy to find uh good or decent moves so
if he just plays a move like i don't know queen
g5 i'm trying to think what what else to do
but yeah queen g5 played and it's like okay
doesn't matter if maybe the evaluation bar
is sitting at 0.00 every player in this game
including you and i uh right now robert we know
this game is not equal and it's not a draw right
that's what's confusing for people they see zero
is like wait isn't that just equality and you
look at the position how and then you have spent
dynamic equality both sides of chances but that's
why you focused on what is happening what the
pieces are doing how they're coordinating you
know how they're working in conjunction with one
another and i like black's position still but in a
few moves this could turn around so you i i don't
even know actually what black should do right now
because i move like bishop to b7 you're sort of
retreating and when i see bishop b7 i even think
in the corner of my eye like queen a7 at
some moment i wouldn't do that right now
but i'm just looking like watch out there could
be a timely move like queen a7 that could get you
in trouble absolutely um you almost want to play
yes so bishop b7 played you can see that eval bar
actually creeping up but kosia probably knows he's
lost some of his advantage i think just because
of the type of moves that have happened over the
last last series here but he also uh i think will
recognize that as long as he keeps pieces on the
board tanya is going to have to play a incredibly
accurate game uh in order to keep that that
advantage that the engine is displaying at the
moment and that's a great first move because queen
f7 is a mating threat and you're putting pressure
on f7 you would like to play bishop c4 but don't
make that move too soon because if you try to
play bishop c4 queen c1 check that rook needs to
stay in line with the c1 square but actually how
does black respond to rook c7 you can't protect
f7 with the rook you drop your bishop on b7 so
i was going to say i feel like you almost go like
king king age seven or something and say look if
you want to go down and grab that pawn with the
queen it's not going to be checked so at least i
get in with some checks of my own and then maybe
i can meet this uh this checkmate threat myself
that's true you know you could slide a rook to
g8 give up that bishop kind of like what you were
saying earlier in that line where like queen takes
d5 queens day you give up a rook on the irrelevant
side of the board so that the king and this in
this case the bishop and the king for white is
very unsafe so i think that you're right that
might move like king to h7 makes a lot of sense
here and great move by the way i know you you
harped on it but brooks c7 like still covering the
c1 square and being aggressive hitting f7 and b7
that's just a fantastic move and i love that she's
ready for the next move she plays rook g1 queen f6
this is definitely trending in tanya's favor and
i think she knows it she's ready to strike and
potentially score going in to the three minute
portion robert and remember how i said queen a7
wasn't good then i think it's good now i think
queen a7 is going to win this game like right now
you attend the russian bishop and honestly there
it is this is why i bring up ideas even when
they seem like they're never going to happen
you want to keep in the back of your head because
if you don't think about queen a7 you'll just
forget about here you'll focus on the king side
i'm going to checkmate that king well you know
how you can check with the king if your queen gets
involved the queen a7 comes with tempo the bishop
is falling this is lights out beautiful move and i
i was saying that that could be the exact momentum
she needs going in to the next format um and look
at that seven losses in a row but fighting chess
every time and tanya slowly seems to be maybe
fixing her mistakes let's see if she can close
this one out before i jinx it robert yeah and i
mean this is a good retreating mcqueen to e3 but
look at the bishops trying to come to d4 she takes
that that's a smart move she says nope yes and oh
she didn't see h2 was hanging it's not the first
time today she forgot about that side of the board
but yep queen c3 okay i like this this d4 is
gonna be played king e3 king e3 is a big time move
okay can you two is played still a good move yes
you might be able to play king e3 next move too
now you can't play e3 but i think
oh queen h2 queen h2 queen f4
oh my gosh she's so happy that that didn't
happen but queen it's you're still happening
wait king c354 okay or queen
e5 and then the rook hangs
well depends where the king goes now there's
checks and oh the rook just hangs with check
i don't know what to say oh no robert i
feel horrible i feel just absolutely gutted
that's so heartbreaking to
watch so heartbreaking to watch
kostya knows he just got away with murder
basically um and he's got that look on his face
like i didn't deserve that but it's not like he's
been undeserving of all the games in this match
and he's upbeat out it's like that was the first
one that that tanya fully deserved the point and
what a defensive effort by her to even get to that
position that looks so lost the king was stranded
in the middle she coordinated all her pieces and
it's just like you get that one moment to maybe
make that small comeback in a match and it it
just barely slips away yeah she turned defense
into offense very quickly and then on the flip
side costa said well she doesn't have that much
time left so let's keep this complicated and her
move rook takes g7 she gives summer material she
was doing the right thing but she could never find
that knockout and that probably caused her some
distress and in the end it cost her not just her
win but it even caused her to lose oh my goodness
well guys you know the score it is eight zero for
costa kavodski and it's gonna take something short
of a miracle in the three minute portion for tony
to get back in this match she absolutely can but
you know slowly but surely it is slipping away
we will be back uh we're now at the end of the
five minute portion we'll be back with the three
plus one portion right after this stick with us
so
and we are excited to get back into the commentary
for this match between kosice kovetsky and tanya
sachdev but first want to remind you about
pogchamps 3 presented by grip 6 which chess.com
is hosting yet another edition you can see the
participants on your screen there uh i'm i'm just
looking at all these names robert and i'm excited
to see guys like logic getting in there we've seen
um the v tuber code miko as well as myth from uh
tsm uh getting involved any names stand out to you
well you know i've coached some of the players uh
of course there's some excitement of rain wilson
from the office taking part and a lot of these
players have been practicing very hard i've seen
nico and michelle in recent days they've been
playing a lot of chess so i hope they're ready
for when the time comes they're not too nervous
they're all doing a great job yeah and this will
be an exciting tournament you guys have maybe
seen previous editions of pogchamps so you know
what to expect not the highest level of chess but
the highest level of entertainment guaranteed so
that's coming up robert but right now we've got to
focus on the i am not a gm tournament and the next
format uh of this this match is gonna be the three
minutes so three minutes plus one second um is is
this gonna be sort of like what you were saying
robert about how tanya sees five minutes as i
have tons and tons of time and playing too slowly
is this gonna wake her up to to playing quicker
i think it will i think it's a more natural time
segment for her and just for most players in
general and i just want to give credit to costa
kavutsuki because i'm i was thinking during the
break just now is this the best performance we've
seen in a and i am not gm speeches championship
imagine the rival performance i would say was
john bartholomew against elena kashlinska in the
final where he went i think six nothing in the
three-minute portion so this is one of the best
performances tanya is super strong and she hasn't
been playing that poorly it's not like she's just
allowing him to just win games no he is
really playing some stellar chess and i
it's clear he's worked hard i think last year's
loss has motivated him to bring an even better
kosher kavetsky to this tournament yeah you said
it well um kosia deserves all the credit for
sure because he's managing a lot of different
aspects there's like the whole chess aspect
there's the practical aspect this is blitz chess
and he's also managing the clock very very well
so he's putting himself in a position even when
he's maybe lost on the board which has only
happened once in the entire match and is in that
last game he still put himself in a position to
potentially succeed because of the clock and
how tricky he was able to make the position
that's right and for tanya i mean it must be
painful it must be frustrating to be in this
situation where like i'm really not playing that
badly but every time i look over and i glance i
have 30 seconds left to my opponent's two minutes
and that's what's really bogging her down to this
point the opening struggle i think has been won
by kosia in most of these games with the white
pieces coach just put her in a tough spot with his
trophowski and also in these kind of queens game
of decline positions and here we see c4 so instead
of these uh lines where the bishop came out early
we're getting back to our uh queen's game decline
positions yeah and people need to remember this is
a match between i was at the seventh and eighth
seats so it's it's right down the middle and if
you look at their ratings now i might say oh 2300
against 2500 well let's remind people they started
at 24.50 each and costa has been winning all the
games so he's shot right up and tiny has gone down
in the other direction so this is like on paper
definitely one of the closest matches and that's
why it has to be said that kosi is putting up
one of the best performances that that we've
ever seen just in terms of the strength of
the players involved yeah and the winner of
this eight nine matchup goes and plays number
one overall seed greg jihadi and i'm sure greg
is probably in the chat right now saying i think
kostya is aiming for me and that's how greg thinks
he thinks it's all about him right greg but no on
a serious note costa is looking to be an excellent
foreman whatever he is the 809c that seems like
he's under seated based on his level of play
absolutely um we see i guess a uh position
which i'm sure both players are familiar with
this is an interesting setup that i like to go
for as white where you go bishop d3 and knight
g to e2 instead of knight f3 to deal with 94 a
little bit better so you always have f3 available
and f3 e4 by white is actually one of the main
plans in the position that's right and i like what
tanya did there when you have less space you want
to trade some pieces so that your pieces aren't
stepping on each other's toes she trades the darks
for bishops she plays a5 to make b4 a little bit
more difficult and right at this point rook a to
b1 was played trying to get in b4 but watch out
for some play on the king side oftentimes black
plays music h5 maybe knight g4 things like that to
have a surprise attack against the white king yeah
i'm used to white playing h3 in these positions
because the move knight g4 is so annoying h3
doesn't stop mate and g3 is absolutely not
the move you want to play so taking advantage
of that knight not being on f3 watching over
uh h2 like he usually does going to e5 like it
usually might knight g4 i think even just throwing
it in is really strong here because who wants to
play g3 and moves like knight f4 and knight g3
keep in mind a very you know common tactic is like
knight g4 knight g3 and then hey you want to kick
that knight out with h3 well knight takes e3 runs
into issues already that's certainly true and she
plays 96 which is a calmer move i still like the
look of knight to g4 but i understand why she was
playing knight to e6 she'll play bishop d7 her
position remains solid another idea for black is
well she'd been knight to g5 she's going for the
aggressive plan but i was going to say that black
sometimes can play b5 before white does so because
white wants to open up the queen side and use the
rooks there so if you play b5 for black you get
this weakness on c6 but you're getting a c4 square
potentially for a knight yeah b5 is uh is a nice
idea if it doesn't get played i was gonna say if
tiny's not playing b5 i think she's full committed
to the king side here we might see ideas like g6
h5 and she's already started with that h pawn
advance and h4 by kostya to middle move robert
what do you make of h4 is that going to be one he
regrets later i think he felt it was absolutely
required because if black plays h4 there's going
to be a huge attack so he says i'll play h4 but
i don't like the look of it there's already i use
a knight g4 for black if you take my knight in g5
i push my pawn to h4 and just try to checkmate
the king she prints her name like that h7 so
so she keeps her bishop on c8 open although
is there now knight takes h5 as a tactic the
knight f6 is a bit overloaded there yeah
knight takes h5 i'm even looking at bishop
takes h7 but knight h5 is just the better way
to do that tactic you take on h7 go back to f5
yeah it's one of these positions where you are
trying to attack so sometimes actually having
fewer pawns is good because you get open files but
you're not getting a rook to h8 anytime soon at
least not that i see but she can go after this h4
pawn it's more advanced which makes it vulnerable
yep and this is already looking kind of bad like
knight takes f6 is playable but even just knight
back to f4 maybe even go g3 at the right moment
bishop f5 look for trades this is looking better
and better for costa here knight c to e2 and just
just you know back that knight up and that's the
thing is she went knight g5 to h7 she could
have just played knight to e6 to start with so
she made this secured his route to the square she
could have gone to immediately and she dropped the
h5 pawn so it's still not game over there's plenty
of life left look at that move knight g4 watch out
queen h2 is checkmate if you play g3 look out for
a sacrifice on the e3 square coming your way and
if you take on g4 bishop g4 you regret having
your pawn on h4 you really wish that pawn could
push itself back to h2 or even h3 and now look
at this queen h6 rookie 6 rook g6 there could be
a blistering attack big fan rook e6 is such a
comfortable move defends the only weakness in
the position for tanya coming over to g6 with
bishop f3 and we might see a beautiful sax mate
type of position that's what i'm looking for
and bishop f3 could be considered even if your
rook's not in g6 yet because sometimes you give up
that piece to break open the position the h4 pawn
is hanging do you need to defend that pawn g3 no
don't do that oh oh my eyes robert you said don't
do that and it was like on a dime immediately g3
was played and what is going to happen here how
does costa could get out of this one rook g6 is
coming rook f6 i think g5 is as soon as g5 happens
it it should be close to lights out i mean how
do you stop g5 now i don't know knight d3 to e5
wow but even there g5 takes h4 and yeah the attack
continues so just take that and go to g5 okay it's
a fine move as well but you were right though
but taking it she probably thought saw that h7
square is not available so there's a background
checkmate but g5 in addition to attacking the
knight and trying to probably give the king
the g7 square and she there's g5 yeah there
is g5 a very good position knight g2 you have to
play knight g2 and there even could be a queen
sack here like i could see a position where
you sacrificed your queen for a knight on h4
yeah okay h5 and weaseling your way in and tanya
plays queen h5 that looks good to me instinctively
yes and she's 12.6 seconds up 30 seconds left
for white easier to play for black but that
clock situation is scary what's white's move here
rook c7 is c6 actually hanging she's bishop before
okay so queen d1 bishop back to f3 looks like
it has to happen yes yep okay and that's you
don't make a draw don't make a draw i think you
can go back one more time i can't remember no but
she had to play bishop f3 there it was the issue
was going back to e4 she should have gone queen
to g4 and queen h3 robert another amazing chance
for tanya down the dream yes at least she's on the
scoreboard so she can feel better about that game
she played pretty well there she blundered upon
and yet she still had a pretty good position and
that's the sign of playing good chess is even when
you make some kind of crazy oversight you still
have some good chances right now she fixed the
problem of the earlier game she played d5 rather
than having these triple pawns this is standard
play against the kings indian you play a3 group b1
b4 black's gonna try to play f5 so you're playing
an opposite side of the board this is kind of in
her wheelhouse yep i like it knight d3 f3 we might
just see uh okay g4 wow she's really anti-f5 there
i'm very anti-g4 that's a move that i wouldn't
have even considered but if you could stop your
opponent's attack before it even begins then maybe
g4 is a good move and i'm just unaware of this
as a concept right yeah even like knight d3 and i
i feel like you got to play f5 as black but kosia
he's showing some patience here just going bishop
h6 trying to get rid of the positional deficit
that he has that dark square bishop with this
pawn structure wasn't looking too pretty on g7
he's trying to fix that before he proceeds but
can't white just play a3 okay this all makes sense
you're shutting down the king side and then you're
gonna be the side who controls the pawn break
on the queen side and now what's black can do f5
that doesn't scare me you play f5 i can even take
it and open up the g file but making moves like
knight f7 back and forth a3 b4 i'm not saying that
white will win necessarily because black can play
b6 and try to be solid but black is very passive
here and white at least has aggressive intentions
yeah and and i think king g2 is very reasonable
here a3 rook b1 b4 those all need to happen um
he's up a full minute already kocia has used
six seconds right there's plus one on this uh
on this match so he's getting you know 18 seconds
added because there's been 18 moves so far but
still he has used almost no time and i like that
move g5 he is locking up most of the action on
the king side but controlling the pawn break h5 at
the right moment could be scary knight h8 knight
there it goes knight g6 and either into h4 f4 the
good news is you have a knight on d3 so the knight
can't really get into f4 and look at her she's
taking the petrossian king walk going over to the
queen side i guess yeah i think she really needs
to play a3 i'm glad she has just before black
plays knight c7 a6 and gets b5 in for himself it's
really important i think for white to get b4 first
this is a fascinating struggle she can you know
blacking over b5 now but that knight went to d1
to go to e3 and perhaps into f5 so you you have to
figure out where your attention belongs but really
chess is about full board awareness you have to be
looking at both sides and here h5 has happened and
b5 that will happen later and for white you could
play knight five check or you can play b4 like
what is the way to go here but i think this is
a miss you're supposed to have h3 in so that
you can take back with the h pawn um and she's
sort of been forced into this knight f5 thing but
after knight f4 i think most players would look
at that bishop versus knight scenario and say
look i don't know what the evaluation is but
should be kind of good for for the knight yes
because if you take on f4 e takes f4 knight b8
knight d7 95 thank you very much for that dark
square outpost in the center of the board you can
still break open the position of g5 to g4 later so
i would not take that knight but if you don't take
that knight that's gonna work oh i like that h4
i think that's a super important move and uh
full credit to tanya for finding that i think
it was like absolutely necessary because now
if you like take that that completely opens
things up you can slide the rooks over to the h
g files and maybe play on the king side that's
right because instead of locked up position for
this light square bishop if you play knight d3
and then take on h4 or something like that then
why could play f4 continue to open the position
for the bishop i like this decision by costa you
take me on g5 i take with my f pawn the h5 pawn
becomes a past pawn and he's just trying to keep
the position quite close for now and he's going to
take over the dark scores if pawn captures ever
happen still a tense position i i think overall
in a blitz game i would always take black just
because i feel like white has to be so precise to
to somehow uh come out on top here i think she's
playing good moves but as the time gets lower
she's not going to be able to continue that
at the same you know level of accuracy and
the knights just so easy to play with easy to
play in the dark squares here for black that's
right and there's ideas for black for c takes b4
and then a5 give me the c5 score for my knight
white i would play rook h1 robita g1 and just kind
of assume that my queen side is okay but bishop
d1 taking advantage of black's last move when he
played b6 the light squares become more vulnerable
she's trying to play bishop a4 into c6 that
could be really annoying for black to deal with
absolutely absolutely and kostya has is kind of
in no man's land he has to pick a side of the
board to play on and if bishop takes d7 happens
all of a sudden there's no knight sinking into
e5 and i think tanya's rebound their bishop d1 and
a4 is top notch and she should play b take c5 soon
and then a485 and just rookie it's bad because
then bc5 you can't take with the b pawn if the
rooks are not connected with one another and you
don't want to take with the d pawn because then a4
a5 is a thematic pawn break from white's point of
view and actually voice position looks excellent
tanya is completely winning here this knight can't
go anywhere a4a5 uh now just works knight takes f4
a4a5 the time is the only issue but i love the way
she's playing and she can even punch through a d6
move because if you take on f4 with the g pawn
rook g1 check and you're trying to run away king
f7 your king is not running too far goodness dixon
queen d5 check and that's me this is this is lost
for sure even just doubling slowly can't be that
bad watch out for queen d6 rook takes c6 cheese
and then yeah that would be the one thing to
keep an eye on so 26 would be a good move it
also blockades the pawn and then maybe rook c7
but you're right eventually white will play rook
b1 to g1 bring the queen over there that knight is
locked into the cheese rook yeah there's rook g7
so it might not work here but i'm not sure yeah
you have to go for it yeah he's gonna try it king
h6 and i think the idea is you just move the king
and play queen g2 has to be made nice yes king
one queen g2 and the queen g6 queen sack for me
absolutely there's no other way to do it robert
gotta be the queen sack and it's funny because not
only are you lying queen g2 you're threatening d
takes c6 because your queen's defended on d2
so that's not just king f1 king e1 i love it
multi-purpose move well what is this gonna be this
is gonna be a draw into a win into tanya showing
some comfort level with this three minute portion
yeah and even though she was down on the clock in
this game she played much better and you could see
that her plans made sense they were connected with
one another she did make sense in the first
time control but something about this time
patrol she seemed much more accurate and allow
the checkmate i would allow the checker queen g6
very nice that's a good sport there we go i saw
uh coaches face and he was like well done he just
smiled and acknowledgement that's that's really
respectful he's got that uh got that smirk like
yeah you know that was that was good you know hat
tip hat tip and amman i don't know about you but
i often allow my opponent to checkmate me because
it's no difference if i lose the game by resigning
or i get checkmated i lost the game but some
people have this huge aversion to getting checked
i think it's like the most insulting thing to
their ego ever so it's i guess a matter of style
but i'm very happy that kosia played that's
on me yeah like people like me for example
the amount of times that i've been like checkmated
in in a beautiful way is probably zero there's no
chance zero chance i give you that satisfaction
you know how how good tanya feels right now this
is come back season baby i would never ever give
my opponent the fuel to the fire that's gonna
maybe uh burn me okay i feel that also you know
like in basketball slam dunk is a poster you don't
want the image of the checkmate just on a frame in
the wall uh yeah behind you so i get you and tanya
by the way has gone back to the line we saw in the
very first game and it had scored good results for
kosia but she took with the queen she did not
like the isolated pawn so she takes the queen
it's a turn in development bishop came to c4 with
tempo now white and castle but black is more solid
compared to the iqp and now take this pawn and
interestingly enough queen takes there's bishop f6
and i don't actually think that's good for uh for
cost yet so i would have taken that pawn early
and i almost think that e takes might have been
forced in a weird way i don't know of course it
would have played that way that's right yeah
it's true and i guess here with that annoying
pin on the d4 point maybe knight e5 we saw him
do something like that in the previous game
well actually he's going to be the
one with the isolated queen pawn
yep but the thing is he has really good control
over d5 it could be the idea to go rook d1 d5
i would definitely consider 97 yes 97 standards
have moved to try to plug the d5 square if your
opponent has an isoqueen pawn you want to blockade
the square because the idea is often to push that
pawn which opens up the board and the pieces so d5
was played does it work though i think just bishop
b2 right yeah bishop b2 take and then you know
you just like pile up bishop e6 97 and it seems
like the best that kosu could do is maybe win it
back but i'm feel like i'm not convinced robert
i'm not either and i don't think tanya is as
well because i'm looking at her she says okay
i'll take that bishop e6 she completes her
development and or 97 first she can choose
which way her bishop goes i like this this is
more flexible because perhaps a mantra played
bishop g4 or something like that if you're not
careful so yes she chose wisely at that point
yep i think bishop e6 is also consideration but i
think she might stray away from that there's some
like knight knight d4 and hg5s uh in the world
that don't look the easiest whereas bishop g4
makes a nasty type of threat you can always drop
back to e6 right away that's right so bishop g4
pinning the knight trying to take it off the board
and if you get enough trades going you don't feel
bad about your position at all she plays bishop
g4 so 97 that's just that precise move that she
needed and actually how does white deal with this
because kosi is down upon and it doesn't look like
he's winning it back no i i'm literally about to
play just bishop e2 like there's no way i can deal
with doubled and isolated pawns on f3 well he
says what he says you know he says hey double
isolated pawns at f3 yes please but this looks bad
the queen's coming to h4 the knights coming to f4
not good the one thing though is this bishop is in
the perfect place for white hitting the f7 pawn so
you have to be a bit careful if you're tanya but
i like queen h4 and going for an initiative maybe
queen f6 is a little safer but either way you
kind of like queen f6 i don't know why it seems
to watch f7 uh maybe not as committal then one
of the reasons why i wasn't so sure about this
was was actually going to be a rook e4 or
rook d4 move because after knight f4 you pin
yourself and there's no like queen g5 because
that's covered for the moment that's true so
she played yeah and my question was like not
queen f5 because that blunders knight h3 queen d4
but queen e5 and we cover queen g5 to me and we're
hitting the knight g5 is super committal so i'm
not sure about this i am with you there queen e5
rook a to e8 those are one of those moves that
like you try you try to get tactical but the
problem there is after queen takes e8 and like
knight h3 check and all this good stuff to win
the rook on d4 you're you're getting bit mated
very quickly but it's the opposite if you go queen
e5 rook a8 queen e8 queen g5 you get mated so you
have to start with bishop takes f7 check and rook
f4 well see that that's a ko i blunder checkmates
cos you're probably seeing those same ghosts and
oh wait i could be mated that's why he played rook
to e4 and now you can take the queen but then
the queen on h4 will be captured and the bishop
is stronger than the knight with pieces on pawns
on both flanks and the pawn f7 being a target so
knight h3 queen takes f7 by the way keep that
in mind yes queen f7 is a puzzle rush that costa
is just he's just frothing at the mouth for
that and look at this his king is going to h3
and is there a check rate like king h4 h6 is
that possible or after h6 does white just play
some kind of rook g1 and sacrifice you know and
maybe oh my goodness by the way after queen f2
is white playing for a win in any line because
king here king here you always have checks
on g2 h2 f2 right so oh my goodness she's
she's going all in i respect it i respect it
so do i because koji has 45 seconds left
and his king is on h4 so he needs to find
i'm guessing there's like one move because i see
the evaluation bar is like a huge advantage for
white but it's one of these positions where
it's either like winning or it's losing yeah
rook g3 queen h2 king g4 there's no f5 keep in
mind so maybe king h8 is a response there just
not even joking king h8 h h5 looks like too
much maybe king f3 oh i didn't even see queen 85
i wonder if she forgot the bishop still
pins the pawn because if the bishop wasn't
there now f5 check works but the bishop
is on yes now this looks lost like rook f4
has to be winning for white and looking forward
there's a queen d1 check but you can just
uh block it with your uh f rook and now bishop
f7 is mate oh my goodness look at this king it's
got no pawns around it it's like you know
you uh people steal your clothes after you
jump in the lake for a swim and you gotta use
tree branches and stuff just to cover yourself
very impressive very impressive uh game by both
players tanya went for it tiny went whole hog
there i i thought that that was actually gonna
result in maybe a win for her but flipped around
by kostya there robert and the the match has
been going at halftime is nine and a half to
one and a half wow yeah and she could have just
made a draw there so i have to commend her for
playing for a win a draw and a loss at this stage
in time that's not it doesn't make a difference
you're down by so many points you just need to win
games so tanya she's played much better in this
three plus one section and we'll see if she's
able to continue the trend yeah stick with us
guys because tanya is showing signs of life in the
three-minute portion and we'll be back after this
hello everybody and welcome to anyone who's maybe
just tuning in we are commentating the match of
costa kavetsky and tanya sachdev and robert um
we're at the halfway point of the three plus one
portion and i think you'll probably join me and
maybe everyone watching and noticing that tanya
is playing significantly better in this portion
managing her time i think we're seeing a whole
new tanya's octave in the three-minute portion we
absolutely are and she definitely wishes that we
could restart the match right now see let's forget
about that five minute portion because if we look
at what's happening in these last three games
she outplayed costa and some of them in this
latest game she had his king on the edge
of the board he escaped credit to him for
finding accurate defense but she's a much more
confident player and her chest has improved
yeah no doubt no doubt and uh what we're gonna
be getting into is the second half of the
three-minute portion so i think there's about
you know 25 minutes or so on the match clock
so she's she needs to collect as many points
as possible so that when we get to the bullet
this get this match can actually be attainable
uh that she can actually win this thing robert
yeah and unfortunately i don't think she plays
that much bullet so it remains to be seen if
she's able to but first things first you have to
do this one move at a time and she's blitzing out
this opening we've seen it before and castle okay
some of the earlier games she played the same is
for the pawn on f3 i was just trying to note the
differences but she's playing this very quickly
we just saw her play a very interesting locked
up game where she was able to break through and
checkmate coaches king so happy memories in this
one yeah she's gonna go for g4 so it's like hey
that was uh that was my only win of the match uh
you're not gonna get tricked me out of playing
that game again sure i'm right back in there and
i like what kosia did in that last game uh his
position looked quite passive but eventually went
g5 knight h8 knight g6 and just try to improve his
positioning of that knight there and i still am
not a huge fan of this i feel like objectively
white just has to be better and yeah tanya
will need to go for a3 and b4 and there it is
so immediate a3 this time and you have to wonder
in this break uh this halftime break that we take
uh you know we're just sort of relaxing taking
a taking a breather but these players they might
be taking a breather they also might be just
checking the lines and i'm always wondering
what are they checking in in the break here is
tanya looking at this specific line and saying
look this is actually the best position i've
had against the king's indian let me double
check this again so make sure to know how to
play this again right and while she's repeating
it it's i think this is the exact game that we
saw is that i think so yeah i don't know if a3
was this early but i i think we've transposed
now to the exact game yes and we saw cozy go
to knight h8 knight g6 and knight in and she
played king f2 last and maybe you should play
h4 early so like knight and now h2 or is that
possible i totally agree i i like h4 as an idea
i think she might be looking at takes in knight g6
as maybe like i don't get that pawn back so easily
but i think h4 is great i also think even just
each three and getting ready to meet h5 with
potentially capturing with the h pawn is possible
as well that makes sense soon and there's another
idea she went knight d 193.95 last time perhaps
she'll start with knight d1 before playing b4 and
hey there's h4 so she's playing the aggressive
way fantastic move in my opinion so if it gets
taken i think she just goes rook to h1 and look
i will i will take this h-punt at some point
in this game that says there's no way around it
and you can do so by playing knight e1 knight g2
knight takes h4 as you said there's nothing that
black can do to protect it and she plays knight d1
to e3 this also makes sense and if she gets knight
five with check good luck to that king on g7
yeah and how would you deal with counter play
like this it's always a kind of important question
do you take my first instinct is b3 which is what
time i played the reason i don't like b3 is fully
opening the b file will give black some counter
play with rook b8 and maybe that rook can just
go to b3 and all this stuff so knight e1 would
have solved two different issues they would
have protected c4 with the bishop but also allowed
the knights to come to g2 but still i think b3 it
makes sense she doesn't want to have to think too
hard about the position her plan is now very clear
yeah knight f5 is basically a win on the
spot if it can happen so i think king h8
we'll see from costa would be surprised
to see a different move uh also the speed
i didn't even have to look at the clock because
i know just you know that game sense that flow
when you feel like one move is coming just
as fast as the other you get uh you get that
feeling and i can feel that tanya is playing
very quick this game and that's why you see on
the clock she has another time advantage great
to see knight f5 super strong if it gets taken
you take back with a g pawn and hey those those
rooks are both participating all of a sudden and
now the rook on h1 is a very happy camper
knight takes h4 let's open that h file
go for that king in the corner and black just
isn't in time with any counter play it's not
like you could sacrifice a pawn and get your
knight in the game the knight c7 is actually just
not doing much of anything it doesn't have a true
future to help so i would probably just take on
h4 but you have to think about f5 at some moment
like knight h4 knight takes for f5 maybe there's
some tactic because the rook isn't defended very
well on h4 but that should not be a good point
i like queen h6 first there's another idea just
threaten mate and then play knight takes h4 um
at least it definitely deals with the f5 so maybe
i see that f5 thing that you just mentioned and
it's like okay i don't even want to calculate that
let's just play queen h6 but she goes for this and
like you said there's no way it's bad queen h6 is
going to happen anyway right you're doubling the
rooks bringing the queen in and h7 feels like it's
just going to be a goner but the thing about these
positions amman that frustrate me is i know some
of the obvious plans maybe rook h1 maybe queen h6
but how do i actually checkmate black and
i need to bring another piece into the game
but the problem i'm starting to see at the
corner of my eye is this rook coming to b8
if i can time rook b8 well right now there could
be some issues where i can't just bring all my
pieces over to the king side f4 that's a nice move
i think because you're marching your pawns forward
maybe that bishop e2 will get into the game
as well as a g5 and stuff like that but that's
too risky right now yeah and what a move f4
like i would think twice about that positionally
but tanya looks like she's full committed to
this attack and she's ready to just play f4
uh get that knight involved takes knight takes
f4 there's ideas like knight g6 knight to e6 as
well bishop a6 though by costa he's finally using
that bishop wasn't doing anything from c8 finally
we see the first real threat from from black's
position and queen c3 i like that move she says
i'm still going to have an attack and maybe she
will play bishop d1 bishop a4 i don't know if
that amounts to anything but at least it
improves the bishop and look at coaster
h8 now knight eight is there some kind of
breakthrough like a g5 and open up the diagonal
probably not yet with your king on f2 yeah my
instinct after knight a8 was to play king g3
or king e3 or even king back somewhere and then
almost like you're ready to almost sacrifice on
e5 with the knight on d3 so i'm looking at like
sacking on e5 as an idea yes and rook beats you
play whatever bishop takes c4 this is the counter
play five that's needed g5 bishop takes c4 that
probably scared her so she went queen to c1 which
i think is a very good move actually yeah oh g5 is
coming though yeah it really looks it really looks
scary because what i'm looking at is g5 g6 take on
h7 and then rook h8 sacrifice with queen h1 to
h7 mate nice this is actually just overwhelming
rook takes e2 king takes e2 the c4 pawn's
defended that queen on c1 is in the right place
and that king on h8 is not yeah g6 is a huge
move next uh if that happened i mean taking
f6 looks strong as well but g6 looks really
forcing as long as she notices that queen h1
i really like that mating pattern you showed
and i think this is a good practical try
by coastian and g6 she says i don't care that's
one check on c4 king goes right back to f2 and
same situation 49 you're down exchange and
you're getting mated checks on a2 king g3
king takes f4 if necessary king's actually
mega safe there now here we go this is the
rook h8 mate that you've mentioned yeah and so
we're gonna see rook hey cheat i hope she goes
queen h1 i mean you can't falter after king g3 she
knows there's no more checks after either king g4
or king takes f4 yeah i like kg4 because you
don't even see a single check and yeah it's
mate yeah f5 king g5 you know if necessary
can you take it do whatever you want yeah
okay now queen h4 there's not a check anyway okay
rook f7 queen sevens mate nicely done beautiful
game rook f8 here yes nice and that's just the
cherry on top a beautiful game there's no other
way to say it that was a crush and are we going to
have to see for the first time costia revisit that
opening robert it's so weird because i got to
give so much credit to tanya right now i looked
at that opening that kosi played and well it's
not the best opening i kind of look at the dark
squares i'm like yeah that's that's really solid
but tanya just makes it look bad she's played so
much better in this three plus one time patrol and
she's punishing that opening it feels like kosia
knows that it's a bit risky but that there are
also some things that need to be worked out but
in this time control he's the one who's under
more pressure and tanya's been punishing it
yeah it's great stuff and what we need to see is
maybe for the first time in this match we need
to see that energy that she gets with the white
pieces and those beautiful checkmate wins is by
the way it's been two amazing checkmate attacks
with that opening she needs to transfer that
to the black pieces if she gets a win with
the black pieces two in a row i can see that
momentum if it's not already shifting like i could
see it fully shift in the other direction she
gets the white pieces again another win she could
dominate as she already is she could dominate this
three-minute portion right and she's down seven
points right now but i just looked at the clock
just 15 minutes left in his time control that
could be good for like three more games and so
yeah if you start winning you start feeling better
about your chances you're still going to be the
underdog but it's way better than it has been and
look at her knight to b4 taking with the d5 square
i'm going to blockade your iqp b6 bishop b7 now
your pawn is a not necessarily a weakness exactly
but in the style of cappa blanca the longer
it stays there the worse it gets for the side
with the isolated pawn and the interesting thing
about isolated pawns is that my understanding is
the bishop from c1 wants to be on g5 or at that
diagonal and then when the bishop's on b2 with
with b3 played i i think that's just a bad version
of an isolated pawn you don't want this bishop b4
punishes that really nicely it gets so many trades
in the position i think that costa just has a bad
isolated pawn here he does and she finds bishop
before 94 is a devastating threat trying to win
some material now you can play rook c8 trying to
trade everything on c3 play b5 winning a piece
but you're right that's a very instructive point
that amman is making the bishop wants to be on g5
and the reason why is when you've isolated pawn
you have two open lines that's the nature of an
isolated pawn the c and the e files are open
for your rooks and you want to be active and
wow wasn't expecting that was going on a long rant
there then i seen 94 and now if you think what is
happening i okay so my first instinct is that it's
it might work but it looks unnecessary loved her
position here after rookie one rook c8 looked
like a great build up but let's just see her
idea knight takes c3 uncovering with that bishop
still on b4 wow so okay so bishop c3 you take
out z3 the rook hangs on e4 rook g4 played and if
knight takes d1 queen h6 coming oh my goodness yes
i think you have to take on d1 and then g6 happens
and you take it and the very least that's a draw
but that's not something you want to play into
that's black no and not in the slightest and
because if you don't play knight takes d1 your
knight on c3 is hey you have yeah i think you
almost have to knight d5 i guess is the other
way and then queen h6 queen f6 idea okay that's
actually might be a nice way to save the game
and save your king because it's really scary
to allow this queen h6 and you'll be down at
full rook but that king of jade lacks defenders
and this is an example where the bishop on b2
suddenly looks good from b2 hitting g7 it's like
wait what that worked out too well she had the
ideal situation the blockade makes that bishop on
b2 just looked like a defensive piece now if you
get d5 for white you're right that's checkmating
attacks of queen h6 like the position is almost
wild enough that d5 is like nearly a move you know
what i mean like you're so close to like unlocking
that bishop for something crazy but i don't think
there's any question queen h6 has to be the move
right and after queen h6 g6 maybe then d5 trying
to mate on those dark squares there wow oh i guess
the knight's hitting the bishop let's not forget
you're right you know it's like that that guy
behind enemy lines and capture the flag you
forget about yes and it also attacks the f2 square
so if you think oh i'm going to go checkmate black
in a couple of moves the queen f6 happens and that
queen threatens the f2 pawn so then d1 is a hero
so knight takes g6 everyone's looking at that
right now but is it enough white is down what a
full rook here so the question is is this more
than a draw that's the question oh she took it
the wrong way i think she took the wrong way
oh my goodness i see the evaluation bar jumping
bishop takes e6 now looks bishop e6 is the move
but how do you even take with the other pawn
that's so counterintuitive fashion e6 is gross
yeah wow what a move you know amon it's funny
because in most situations coach is like capture
towards the center right so h6 g6 it does make
some sense but not when you're being attacked
and now your king is caught oh my goodness
rook takes g6 you can take that and wait i was
gonna say does the bishop participate from b2
but no not quite i think he's like bishop at five
at the end right yeah how how crazy is that what a
calculation rook g6 takes king h8 queen back to h6
king g8 and bishop f5 threatening made on h7 and
you know there's like a battlefield of corpses but
there's just there's just nothing to do about mate
this is checkmate by force and it's going to
be maybe this bishop h7 check bishop back to g6
that's a really nice mating pattern that we
don't get to see too often so we'll see like
rookie eight as bishop h i think i think we'll get
to see it demonstrated unless tiny resigns because
there's no other moves but i feel like
you kind of have to return the favor right
and here we go bishop h7 check king h8 bishop g6
and the queen goes up to h7 where it can take f7
when the king runs away so that's actually why
you throw in the check oh favor not returned
favorite not richard declined just like
when you get a venmo request like thanks
for hosting last night um you know you owe me
this much money no nope rejected you think i do
and we'll see if we get another fascinating battle
in this king's india what an attacking game the
games in the three minute portion have really
picked up in like pace and intensity as well
yes they have and i think in large part that's
because of tanya she's playing much more quickly
and they've been sharper for sure and here we go
this line again is not red okay i was going to say
is he ready to admit that he needs to change and
yes we see f5 that's brand new i like this though
from costume not even just for this match because
it is getting out of hand but as a strategy saying
i am willing in the middle of a time control
to just do these slight changes and you were
getting comfortable in this line now it's like
f5 wait do i take on c6 or she just did or did i
take on f5 do i leave the pawn e4 how do i react
here and this is now true king's indian style
takes on takes on f5 um she's basically opened the
entire center so so now it's a question of is this
center going to be super strong and mobile or is
it going to be picked apart and targeted by by
tanya so chess is just that eternal struggle the
the structure is the same for both players but you
have different perspectives like white's trying to
say hey those pawns are weak black's trying to say
no my center is very strong and i'm going to show
you right and the question of when to push pawns
is a very difficult one you know that d6 to d5 is
not available the e5 pawn needs defense do i play
e5 to e4 wait a second that knight goes into
d4 i give up these dark squares so speaking of
struggles that's one that you have to dig deep
to figure out because any pawn move creates a
weakness in the square that was previously
covering and can we just talk about rook
a to d1 i mean that looks like the the brainless
move that i would play here in about half a second
tax upon how are we going to defend that
we're not but we're going to hope that
hey i'll give you d6 we'll take b2 but you're
right rook ad1 comes in very naturally there
okay and knight c5 played looking for maybe the
e4 square after taking on d6 and i wonder after
queen d6 if kosi will trade queens or like queen
b6 a threat in that 94 idea that you were just
mentioning and keeping it sharper because if
he trades queens i think he's just in trouble
and by the way can we play knight takes e5 here
i was just looking do i need to take on d6 your
pawn is pen that's a good point maybe i can just
steal that pawn that is a very good point knight
takes e5 looks dangerous as well probably a lot
more dangerous than queen takes d6 because it's
threatening knight c6 and you're still threatening
queen d6 on top of all that yeah and b3 okay so
she was tunneled just like we were at first about
this capture on d6 but when you play rook a to
d1 you should think i'm putting two pieces on the
same line so i'm attacking d6 directly but if that
pawn were to lift up i always talk about this too
if there's pieces on the same line if the piece
in between them moves out the way what happens
that would allow you to spot knight takes e5
and tanya now down a minute on the clock and the
onus is still on coast here to prove that he has
sufficient play here i agree i think i think
tanya is still doing fantastic so b3 it may be
an overly safe move but uh can't fault it it's
a blitz game and she's played knight d4 quickly
there's got to be some some killer stuff
here those pawns look too weak robert
yeah just you can move that knight out of the way
maybe knight c2 go after that d6 pawn riding away
like queen f4 to go after f5 and d6 it looks like
black's position is on the verge of falling apart
great suggestions yeah at this point i think
that cosi played e4 so you probably noticed
that that tactic and this is the easiest way to
defend that and now he's just hoping to go queen
e7 maybe like rook do you hate to cover queen f4
great move yeah it's a perhaps the cure is worse
than the disease because he went e4 to keep his
pawns he didn't want to drop a pawn but he's not
even down upon i see the eval bar what does that
say like plus two close to plus two yeah right not
even down one pawn but is two pawns worse so this
is a situation where now knight takes at five uh
the thing is you walk into a pin but you've made
e7 check your queen takes d6 coming black seems
and i love the confidence that tiny played knight
takes f5 a lot of us might uh see that rook on f8
and be like no maybe this isn't right but you just
get that intuition that no this has been trending
in white's direction for a while i'm just going
to take that i know that it works that's chess
intuition for you and look at this stuff yeah
knight takes defile you have to see that and
kosher okay i like what kosher did there though
that knight on c7 is a bit trapped rook takes d6
is there like a rook b7 no because then knight to
e8 so the knight r knight e6 as well the knight's
not getting trapped but i i like the effort from
a bad position yeah i think that's that's a fun
way to play rook d6 i'm kind of surprised that
wasn't played maybe i missed something bishop e5
knows rook c6 and i think she could have grabbed
it but she is down to 25 seconds so maybe bishop
bishop e5 rook c6 rook c8 rook c5 bishop h2
some nonsense that's possible it's possible
well now she just stole that pawn and okay looking
great yeah so extra two pawns the black king is
not saved she should take this one but she's down
to 22 seconds we have seen clock not be her friend
today that is absolutely true she's looking at
um maybe bishop e6 or sorry bishop d5 knight e6
uh just to you know get into an obstacle
position where she's up material i think she'd
be comfortable with that rook f7 as well yeah this
is pretty tough for cozy to trade rook f1 check
rook f 98 or rook ups i like g3 i like g3 so
you know get that king to g2 knight e6 next
yeah no rush right you're okay rookie five i
like that b4 when i think might win a piece
and 15 seconds she's 15 seconds that's
coming down to check you got to go to
h3 then bishop g1 maybe oh yeah you don't
bishop g1 connect white king give me two
nobody wants to put their bishop
on jesus yeah i know i know
okay he's going pawn hunting b4 looks normal
here yes where's this king going is it even
running away don't make it i would throw b4 in
throw before it oh she's not trusting her time
no he's not trusting her time that robert
that was a big chance as well for tanya i mean
at this point in the match you sort of have
to look at the score and know that the three
minute portion is ending soon you got to collect
points where you can that's a great chance for her
and this will be the final game most likely of the
three-minute portion unless somebody loses very
quickly and we have a trophowski again look what
he's doing kosia keeps switching his opening up
and i guess actually it was tonya because is
she always starting with one knight of six or
she sometimes starting with one d5 uh sometimes
d5 i think but whenever it's it's uh knight f6
she still chooses she had one game bishop g5
g6 and then she also plays it with the e65
against the trump yeah and i we liked the way
that cozy played that first time f4 knight f3
i think that this is a setup that time does
not enjoy in the slightest and i think that
question made the right choice once again isn't
e5 a move here for black something it looks like
a move that i would consider especially knowing
that f4 has like you know kicked my bum for the
the last couple uh rounds i i just would play it
because i don't want to deal with that f4 anymore
yeah though the problem with playing e5 is
that your center is loose with the e6 pawn
protected d5 everything felt nice and tidy now
you could see the center collapse at the moment
take and do we take oh shimmy 2 is
interesting that doesn't look right
yeah you've moved that bishop to d3 to b5 and
back to e2 so yeah i think that bishop takes
f6 was a better try but instead coaster goes
back and the good thing is he's playing quickly
yeah this looks uh this looks pretty solid
for tanya but um still a bit of like a weird
position let me say like bishop c6 bishop e7
are my instincts to just develop those pieces
yeah probably take that knight g6 though um
looks solid yeah she goes for that she wants
to keep more pieces on the board because white is
more restricted in terms of space so if you have
the spatial advantage and you keep more piece
on the board your opponent has less opportunity
right with their many pieces but do not like that
move no do not like the knight on g6 now is sort
of ineffective and i'm just looking at like you
know queen c2 a4 bishop b5 rook to the d file
looks like easy play for costa and f5 you might
just like never castle or something oh bishop h5
is a great no i was thinking the same thing i was
like you may not castle there's a way i can force
you to not castle by pinning your knight and that
could spell some doom for you so you know what's
problem is when you play d5 takes e4 there was
already a knight on d2 a pawn three squares from a
knight dominates that knight but now that pawn is
gone the c4 square knight c4 right now rook to d1
white is just really moving forward in this
position and black is suffering yeah i mean
if if costa castled here it would be a great
move but rook d1 and knight c4 is a much more
direct way to play queen a2 speaking about
direct holy smokes that is a gutsy gutsy call
wow that caught me off guard i didn't even
think about that pawn right i was like oh
i'm making the normal moves then you do that
nonchalantly then queen takes a2 queen back to a5
i guess the e4 pawn is hanging but black stole
this pawn over there and maybe that can help
her chances but knight takes e4 castle there might
even be some discoveries the queen takes g6 ideas
coming the bishop on c4 pins the f7 pawn exactly
don't like the look of this there's that g6 knight
so just keep in mind bishop pins the f7 pawn so
the g6 knight is loose i still think castling's
the best can't execute any tactics just yet
but just watch that robert mentioned earlier
in this match it was a queen a7 in another game he
noticed it earlier when it didn't work but keep it
in the back of your mind because it processed that
tactical pattern and then when it does work it'll
be it'll be right there for you to access for sure
and so if you're tanya you see that maybe you're
playing like b5 to the cloak there it is close
that bishop off bishop b3 c4 actually traps the
bishop and if the bishops get traded then you
don't have to worry about the tactic but what
you do have to worry about you push your pawns
your remaining pawns become a bit more vulnerable
bishop d5 here just try to get a rook on d5 c5 is
under attack b5 behind it i like kosu's position
regardless great move great movement that's
the type of confidence he needs to end this
portion which has not really gone his way i mean
he hasn't done terribly let's let's be clear but
um but kosia has definitely not done as well
in this section as the five minutes so closing
out with a win the time is officially up going
into the break and into the bullet with you know
12 to 3 lead is exactly the type of confidence and
reassurance that i think he's looking for yeah i
think he's just trying to get a better feel
of these matches in general he at this point
and so tanya they both know that kosher is
going to win this match but you don't want
to take your foot off the pedal because when you
make it to the next round and play greg shahadi
that's going to be another difficult match and
you want to be in it the whole way through you
don't want to take any sort of you know breaks
mentally like oh it's fine i you know whatever
then you lose the game you lose the second game
and then your lead is all of a sudden gone so
i think the coast takes every game seriously
he's that kind of chess player and his position
is good here and f4 he's going for more yeah he he
wants f5 f6 i mean it's telegraphed and with time
ticking down for tanya it's tougher and tougher
to deal with attacking positions easier to deal
with the position if kosio just went you know
rook d5 rook d1 this is going to be much more
difficult he's blasting that position open f6
i love f6 and take that bishop and how do you
actually go and checkmate this king bishop short
knight to oh oh e3 saying i like that actually
that was a good move and it just shows you you
don't have to defend by protecting the pawn or
the square that's under attack you can defend
tactically and here comes the rook to d2 yeah
oh just forgot just forgot the rook yeah oh that's
too bad that's that's probably if i had to like
think of the worst way to end the the three minute
portion that i think that might be the worst way
and wasn't the same with the five minute
portion that final game was one where
she found that queen a7 and all that stuff oh
yeah yeah the final game has not been her friend
yeah that's true actually she hung a rook in both
final games um so man that that is really too bad
um it's 12 to three so basically if this one
minute portion starts and and tanya like doesn't
win the first game or it doesn't show that
she's just an insane bullet player basically
um then you're already starting to to count this
one in the bag for kosia but as robert pointed
out um he's uh never takes the foot off the pedal
right and if i'm her coach or you know her friend
or whatever i'm just saying make every move pretty
much pre-move every move because that's the only
way you have a mathematical chance in this and
when you're playing bullet mistakes happen and
if you have an extra five seconds you just at
least have a little more time to calculate so
it's a tough match through and through costia is
playing very well but if i'm in tonya's camp i'm
just saying go just don't even think just go well
good advice there from robert we'll see if that's
advice that she heeds we're about to take a
break but when we come back there'll be the
one minute plus one second increment portion
to conclude this match stay where you are
and we are excited to get back into this match
hope you guys are still here with us but first
wanted to remind you about the feeding online
world corporate chess championship that's a
mouthful february 19th to 21st and robert there's
gonna be the likes of google taking part in this
and just all those big companies uh anyone you
think is hiding some secret gms out there yeah
there definitely are some companies that you're
like wait a second i know that name that's not
just some casual player in fact i played that
person eight years ago and they they whooped
but what's gonna be cool about that
as well is that teams are able to
get one player over 2500 so i'm sure we'll see
uh the googles or whomever just pick up some
some familiar name where all of a sudden magnus
carlsen is on a team and winning the tournament
yeah i think uh i think a few of those companies
participating they just might have the salary cap
to afford one of those top top players so that
should be kind of a fun less formal event where
um you get to see you know what these with
these companies uh have to offer in terms
of chess so it's an interesting uh initiative
by uh fidei so it is an official event that'll
be fun to watch but robert we're getting ready
for the bullet portion and you mentioned some
advice that seemed good advice uh to my eyes you
mentioned some advice for tanya hey basically
pre-move as much as you can because uh if you're
down twelve to three uh let's be clear you have
to win every single game yeah and i think that
for some players it's difficult because they'd
rather lose by a smaller margin you don't want to
lose by 20 points but a loss is a loss i said this
earlier so if i'm gonna lose this match if i don't
win my games i might as well go down swinging
so tanya just play quickly go for it and for kosia
hey let's see what he has in bullet because this
could be a good indicator of how he'll fare
against greg shotty exactly i think i think
unless he you know completely messes this up
we're expecting to see more of the scene that
consistency um kosi has looked pretty good in all
time controls obviously the three-minute portion
wasn't as good for him but he did win that four to
three so although that was a great uh round for a
great segment for tanya he still won that portion
he just won the first portion so convincingly that
it makes it seem like it was a bad result for
him that's very true and there was that game
where tanya had the fourth straw that she played
on for a win that was informed by the match score
so we'll see how tanya does in the bullet i'm
excited for these games because i feel like
we'll have some tactical flare uh in these next
few yep and uh we're off with the bullet tanya
immediately with d4 and i can see the speed
already from her right i think this is great
this is a good start she's going back to this line
which worked before all the positions that i've
seen from her after playing d5 in this line robert
have been great i'm glad she's playing it again
right so the d6 e5 line which was sharper this hat
gives her a clear plan and we just saw her play in
this variation she had a nice game bishop g5 and
in that one show 22 rook 81 went after the d6 pawn
and i'm guessing she did well we see kosair with
knight c5 instead of bh that's the first different
part of the game so she did something that she
didn't do last time she played h3 and then bishop
g5 last time she played bishop g5 cosi responded
with knight back to f6 so that whole h3 pawn
just simply wasn't there and i think she maybe
just forgot that played so quick in bullet she
didn't even notice or maybe she looked at it and
realized that kosi's knight back to f6 was a bad
move and so she's just trying to come up with
the right plan but you're right that inclusion
didn't seem noticeable to me and said we have this
pawn d6 hanging but the bishop one g5 needs the
queen's defense and if d5 the e5 pawn is hanging
this is a mess amman it is a mess it is a mess
rook ad1 is the move i want to play but i'm
looking at d5 is that coming what a decision what
a decision i think she was worried about some sort
of f4 but then you can take on f6 if that happens
right and right now i think she or the h3 pawn is
hanging from kingdom but b5 you need to take over
the light squares so try to get your knight into
the center of the board but she was 94 similar
idea i think that's reasonable c5 is what i want
to do yes c5 d5 knight d6 even just you know plant
plant that piece in there and i think coach
just playing very accurately right now
he can play d5 play e4 with tempo against that
queen on f3 starts with rook to g8 that makes
some sense but d5 is not harder to play move that
knight out the way knight c3 hit the c6 pawn stop
d5 because the e5 pawn is hanging and there she
finds it yep i like it and in terms of threats on
the king side well h5 is looking to play bishop g4
and create one so i love bishop d3 as a response
yeah h5 is like brilliant because it seems like
what are you doing why would you weaken your own
king but you're right bishop g4 was a nice way
to play and look at the light square domination
by tanya here b5 go b5 oh yeah okay if a5 then she
can play b5 that's fine as well um b5 now we need
b5 she's forced into it right he's just saying i'm
going to break open the side of the board and she
plays that drops a pawn does drop a pawn she's
getting an end game here but that's not going
to be an end game she wants rook before it by
black so that if you want to trade the rook comes
up to d6 which is where it wants to be yeah and
rookies before it is it's a nice move where you
don't get the night in the center on time so black
is up a pawn still good chances to hold this game
and she'll get 22 seconds to coast is seven
six counting down you gotta move rick takes e5
on h5 singing with check as well so i don't think
kosi is playing this well but time is a factor
yeah and her king is in trouble but she has
time to calculate he has knight to d1 king to h2
she's not losing on time that's usually her
in time trouble bishop d6 maybe yeah okay h3
so does that knight come to g4 knight f2 and g4
sometimes hanging on d1 nice hanging super hanging
oh no yeah yeah that's going to be too much
she played too quickly rookie seven me as well
that's two pawns g7 g7 i think she was
just gonna sack or he was gonna sack and
push rather yeah bishop f2 although it's
not mate no we just push the pawns yep
just c3 c2 oh rook out for this bishop e5 for
good measure and now queen yeah that's too much
and that's going to be the first game of the
bullet portion i mean basically i think if this
match was uh near level at this point the way
the speed that tanya is showing in this portion
i think she would have a chance the main thing
is is just too far out of hand at this point
yeah as soon as the five plus one came to a close
it was sort of beyond hope i would say and she's
playing much much much better in the quicker time
patrols and you're right that if she started with
the three-minute just the way and we could remove
the longer time control of those seven losses she
would have played a bit differently in some of
these moments but kostya would have as well right
when you have that big lead sometimes you just
say ah you know it's okay i can go but i have
to give both them credit the way they've been
playing in particular kostya throughout this
whole match he's been quite dominant yep and what
we saw was a little amendment to the move order
after knight d7 he didn't play bishop d3
first played f4 stopping that e5 move which
he did not like he definitely did not like that
opening bishop d5 and this is already nasty for
for tanya yeah you're going to play d takes c5
rook to bring a rook to d1 you can also let bishop
c6 take upon e4 if you want but why not just
increase the pressure on the pin piece she's got
a castle here i think it's the only move yes and
then bishop takes d7 i guess is the response and
you have at least one castle queen side yeah
rook a7 knight c6 that's game over and there's
yeah i think she'll just resign here actually yep
so another another win for gossip i think that uh
setup that he's gone for has been highly effective
uh in this match especially d4 e3 f4 with that c1
bishop already developed that's just that's just
great uh great idea it's worked like a charm for
him and i'm guessing based on the way that coach
just played when he does move on and play the next
match we'll see different openings from him he's
a principal player he sticks to what works for him
but now that his opponent for the next round can
see what he does i think that he'll change it up
and bishop g5 there now this time she didn't play
h3 so now she's back to the original idea of rook
b8 rook d1 here so i wonder what kosi is going
to play knight c5 again would probably be a good
amendment yes you're right and she'd have to play
h3 which was just a movie you don't want to play
it's a waste of a move so rook to d1 there's
knight e4 ideas and that's what you have to
look out for maybe knight f to e4 is that possible
giving up your queen to take a white screen on d2
definitely yeah i think you you want to use
that knight um for sure queen e8 well it's
bullet so you got to take on d6 isn't that the
rule you just got it free pawn take it even if
it costs you something take there put queen to
e7 if you need to if the knight comes to e4 so
i think that she can just snag it will she oh the
the time being spent here is already making me say
she probably won't but i'm happy that she decided
to anyway i think it's the right idea take on e4
queen e7 right she does exactly that knight takes
g5 do not take the queen on eight because knight
takes f3 is check and even that's not so clear
actually because the bishop will take on c6 at
the end so maybe i would have taken on e8 and say
yeah it's a blunder most the time but you take
it a half step further you realize that bishop
would take on c6 hit both rooks and a and eight
yeah who knows what happens after that this is two
bishops um for for cosine because of this bullet
even if this wasn't bullet it'd still be a
game but because it's bullet it's accentuated
knight takes e5 though bishop music what a blunder
yeah and it's an easy blender to make because your
bishop's on the uh diagonal the queen looks
like it's on the same file but still just take
the pawn run away with it bishop takes b2 rook g8
coming maybe this can be a quick attack for costa
okay queen h6 looks fine rook b7
is an idea just stopped by queen e7
okay and i'm still looking at rook b7 if you
play like rook g like can i be seven can i play
it yeah it's a funny oh no but queen g7 at the
end threatens me darn it looks so good now you
can do it though you could have done it right
there and trade queens and rook takes e6 but
chances missed 91 guards g2 uh they're down to
15 16 seconds apiece and this is not looking
very good for white anymore black's attack looks
very legitimate and white is just trying to come
up with some threatens mate so you have to play
h6 yeah and wow what a move queen f5 with limited
time in the clock yeah wow f3 play that's a tricky
move g3 solid and if you play knight takes f3 and
x suddenly you're just completely winning right
it's the committal decision to play f3 the g5
closes down trade queens take on f3 take on a7
oh look at that rook seven's meat wow what a move
oh my god what a move and now you
trade and take and now 95. 95.
you know she's gonna go knight she sticks like
knight she could go nitrogen
knight f8 check just for uh
holy smokes this is why i was saying if this match
was like if the five minute portion didn't happen
this match is incredibly close yes this it feels
like the latter two portions have been a bit of
a toss-up so she's playing so much better she's
kind of found her stride way too late but since
then we've been impressed by the way she's played
so right now she has a situation where look at
this she hasn't committed her pawn to d5 she has
adapted she's not just playing the same thing over
and over again bishop b7 she doesn't have to put
up on d5 you mentioned earlier d6 there she goes
now that knight doesn't get to the e5 square and
and okay so hear me out i see this opening i'm
like tanya where is this opening the whole
match this looks fine cosy is not getting
his f4 95 stuff where was this tiny can play this
position we know she can so i just think in bullet
you start to see people's true in intuition and
tendencies and this her tendency it looks great
yes and the simple matter of fact is she was
overthinking in the five portion five-minute
portions excuse me she was spending too much
time getting in time travel every single game
and look what she's doing she her gut tells
her that i should play in this manner her
position is fine so queen b8 threatens [ __
] picks f3 she's making very logical moves
yeah bishop f3 is a funny move you got to just
bring that rook right back and good move bishop
d5 play c4 your pawn structure is weaker
a little looser maybe bishop c6 and b5 b4
oh look at this tricky move e5 your brook on a3
is under attack once we start trading pawns so
very thematic and e4 becomes a threat very
thematic this bishop can just drop back to f8
as you pointed out is hitting that rook
on a3 so bishop takes f6 played but
i think just even bishop takes f6 can be the reply
i like it the pieces are uh just breaking free
in this position and knight takes f6 the pawn e5
is offended because the rook on a3 is under attack
so justin is trying to play e4 tactically that
move looks possible and as you said bishop fade
as well whoa committal so there's bishop b7
c6 bishop takes f3 i don't know about that
i both hate it and like you at the same time
because she's trying to take over some of
these questions d5 now hits the rook on a3 but
that's very tactical e4 first well that's for d5
but she's missing between h7 yeah he missed it
as well oh so it works now and you can't take
with the rook on a3 because rookie one is mate so
and the brook's covering f7 so hey it worked what
a crazy turn of events there queen e7 okay taking
over the open file i like white's position though
i don't see any huge risk that bishop on d5 is
worth the rook especially with two pawns you have
yep although oh okay rook rook a3 trick bishop
takes f7 although does that work hang on bishop
oh f7 king f8 nice you're right yeah
so what's this this game has been a
series of tactics like quote unquote working and
then wait they actually do work in rook f6 look
what she's doing she swung her rook from a passive
position into an active one look at that i love it
yeah rook d2 love it rook d2 and rook d3 rook
back to d2 you could probably just oh no oh no
i was suggesting it and it runs right into
that how did coaches see that so quickly
well costa would have beaten like tanya you
i mean like he's just taking names right now
it's not enough that he's winning this match oh
my gosh and her plan would just go rook d3 rook
back to d2 and pin the pawn and attack him yeah
exactly oh that's so disappointing for tonya there
and we've seen this opening time and time again
um it seems to be going well for tonya so i
don't blame her for going back
into it no i don't either and
she goes quindy too the rook's coming to d1
we'll see i would use the other rook though
she played rook after d1 i like rook a to
d1 i don't know if there's a big difference
i do too i'm trying to figure out you know
what is the difference she keeps going to work
fd1 okay what is that rook on the a1 where like
what does it need to be like why why is that rook
move the one she goes for but this worked out
last time for her okay so same deal queen e7
knight g5 queen takes the eight possible but i
think she's going to repeat of course yeah and
bishop e6 not played that was a blunder pawn yeah
but can't white just play like rook d6 rook d1 i
like d6 take over the board oh okay knight g5 is
clearly on her mind yeah oh my gosh knight g5 and
there was like rook d8 tactics wow wow yeah
that would be quite special if that happened
rook d8 yeah we're not we're not getting
that right now oh no hey maybe round two yeah
quite possible that would be ridiculous now we're
seeing a repetition yeah can white somehow play
on here mcqueen goes to d6 now no easy to
draw but now that they've found that draw
cosy can repeat that draw every time they play
that game now so tanya has to find something else
yes and we're back to the queen's gambit declined
so right she played c5 and here it goes again
this is back to game one okay so this and i like
that decision we've we've seen this before and i
said the first time yeah like ed5 and knight
c6 and now in bullet we get to see her play
and she's got a crushing position where
was this before d4 now for black might be
playable because the king's in the center so you
quickly break them that's also a good move mm-hmm
yeah take back and that knight doesn't have great
squares to go to knight e5 knight d3 is crushing
wow actually can you even stop that that looks
winning chess can be that simple sometimes huh
maybe you have to play a3 after knight d3 some
sort of lucky save like knight d2 and 85 king
e2 or a3 right away so this is gonna happen and
after knight d3 like a3 she'll play bishop e7
and like bishop f6 all right f5 and then bishop
f6 so she can just kind of take her time i think
that that that should be what gets played but
we'll see bishop b7 and f5 is a great way to play
i think knight b2 is the wrong okay
that's also energy bishop yeah take on
b2 maybe yeah maybe now is a better time to do it
just because uh the pawns on the a file easy to
get but she goes bishop c7 and she wants bishop
e5 oh oh i would have played rook b1 oh there
was knight f2 i guess that's why you played it
i get it now yeah there was a knight f2 threat
how many different tactics are there here it feels
like bishop g4 check it's good f5 is good bishop
e5 i would go f5 i just can't stomach losing that
pawn it's everything you take the pawn f5 happens
and then your knight on c3 drops yeah it has
to shoot okay i would have said pawn f5 but oh
should check made this king somehow stutter step
where's the mate though no just bishop c3 rook c8
probably just simple chess development nice
bishop d2 is going to be played knight takes
they f4 like one yeah she could choose her
which one to take but this is a better one
because knight c2 is next after bishop e1 yes
that's a good call so she made the right decision
and now you take that bishop and you're crashing
through here rook t3 win wins a piece because if
you go 982 you trade rooks and rook d1 check the
end wins the rook in the corner nice wow what a
game beautiful game but that again that's just
like a much better way to play against cosy's
opening almost looks like she's refuted kostya's
line that he's been playing the entire match yeah
it's overthinking right you have five minutes
on the clock oh if this could happen it's what
happens to me in classical chess regularly where i
just spent way too much time thinking about things
that i could have played in five minutes rather
than 20 minutes so okay oh you gave the bishop oh
anymore she needs to get her rook
behind the a pawn that's what she
really needs to accomplish here
oh she got it in front of her k5
nice yeah that's what you want
for h6 oh there's f6 yeah i had the same
exact thought oh f5 is winning it must be
wait f5 rook takes a5 as possible i didn't even
notice yeah me neither i'm like so focused on like
what's happening here but i think she's winning
because she protected her a pawn now rook g8
and then g pawn also runs so okay she should win
this game just a4 king a5 slowly up the board
a3 and there's no rook f3 check this is actually
how you draw these positions when you're down upon
because you like keep checking the king away but
you don't have look after we check because the
pawn on g4 and now it's too late nice game like
tiny is putting some beautiful games together in
the three minute the one minute portion this
is just it feels like a regular match again
it's it's almost like there's this this five
plus one handicap somehow that's in place that
means this match is just over from from that
portion alone yeah she's sticking right with
costa in the bullet and that's kind of surprised
me i would have assumed that the bullet portion is
where costa would thrive and tonya would suffer
but now that she's just playing kind of with a
clear conscience she knows the match is
over there's less pressure in that regard
she is playing better chess yep okay but here here
i was saying they're gonna just repeat this draw
unless tanya does something different so are they
just going to keep drawing this position maybe
or what else can she play so bishop f6 is what
caused the draw rook d6 is the way to stop it yeah
nice they're slowly developing theory in this
line e4 this is looking scary the b2 pawn bishop
or queen to e5 comes to mind i give you knight d4
i'm bored the rook on d6 is in trouble so he plays
knight back to e1 yeah knight d4 queen e5 looks
brutal queen you have rook a to d1 queen takes b2
i don't really like that white is retreating
in this manner but perhaps this activity that
work on d6 can win the c6 spawn and maybe
eventually the white's piece will get out
but if your bishop f1 is the your best move that
it's not so promising yeah agreed agreed maybe g3
knight g2 knight f4 just as a idea to get that guy
doing something wait rook d oh the bishop was the
g8 square returned to i was like is there a back
rank mate rook d8 but no there's always bishop to
g8 yes tricky move queen e7 i like that move
though mm-hmm queen b7 get in there be annoying
for sure then rook b8 to b2
oh okay so rook b8 and then rook b1 and
then bishop c3 that looks lights out
yeah i don't see how to stop that well that's
not gonna help no but i understand why she did
she want to play rookie bishop c4 she's just a
little too slow in that position one move too slow
16 and a half to five and a half um
there's under five minutes left so
hopefully we get um basically as many games as
possible because at this point these are just
entertainment the games have been pretty exciting
in the one minute portion yeah and this house
well they did trump asking they
traded on f6 and yeah the pawn
was there for the taking and it's just
you don't expect your pawn to blunder
it and you're kind of pre-moved even if you
haven't physically pre-moved you've mentally
pre-moved so i understand what both players
are kind of doing here and castling queen side
you know fortune favors the bold but that's
real bold okay i'm playing d5 c4 b5 b4 i'm
just going for a mate yeah it's bullet just just
get in there c4 next b5 i like it okay this is
that fell a little slow c4 b5 your queen should
go to b6 but she's just castling queen side
yeah now i don't think we will see c4 that as
much nah it doesn't look as strong it's funny
bishop a6 says now c4 like blac4 and b5 yeah
c4 b5 a4 please we want to see that attack yes
okay building it up there it is there it is
there it is and here we go here comes the
pawns before now you now you just realized that
black's better like significantly better much
better because normally when you lock up the queen
side white's plans go f4 f5 and he's running away
he is running that king away queen a5 is
definitely the wrong vibe yeah you need the
pawn on a5 right yes and you need to move your
king and here it goes king d1 queen e3 king king
is running to the center oh yeah white's gonna
get a very playable position here bishop d1
he wants knight c2 to cover but i still think
you just shove b4 in yeah that looks too slow
knight f3 now oh queen f3 whoa can i take
on c3 you have to take what the queen
back then wow to protect the b2 square
that looks really good maybe just rook a8
yeah exactly right take over the open file
look at she's playing like whoa okay maybe
it's gross yeah this is oh an f6 thematic
french break i think in that position you just
go b3 and like rook a8 and you just like mate
basically like the king is completely in tone
oh my god crushing game by tanya this
is beautiful queen g3 there's rook f4
wait knight takes before though the attack
goes away and i see the evaluation bar is
freaking out oh you after queen g3 they want
you to move your king and then play b take c3
after queen takes f2 i guess yeah that's a
fourth oh and look how quickly this turned around
yeah it's over now immediately over for for tanya
it's uh 1-0 she grabbed one pawn which allowed the
tactic with the check and then wait bishop is mate
oh no it's not wait no king city before his b3
what he walked into discover check g4 oh my
gosh i should pay for it he thought it was mate
and that's why he did that and now it is made for
real wait oh bishop e2 just rook takes e2 and then
rook d2 and then king c1 and then i move my rook
anywhere and then it's just me it's winning for
sure it's just completely winning rick takes b2
is a great move by the way yeah yeah just next
mover premium rook takes b1 these games are great
robert i'm just i'm just sad that the match isn't
you know swinging in the balance yeah that would
make it much more exciting for us and much more
stressful for the players and well we want them
to be stressed yeah yeah we definitely do that
was a fun game though that was wild like the white
king i thought was mated like seven different ways
and then there's that one little check which
forced black to react i didn't force her to react
she chose to but it that was the natural move
knight took on b4 and all of a sudden white turned
things around and yet she still won the game so
we're back to this and this is where she went h3
and she went like bishop g5 well she's supposed to
play dc bishop g5 without h3 so this is actually
the first time we've seen this position
okay so how should white play this i would
want to play f2 to f4 but i have to move my knight
first and that doesn't look so well okay she's on
the same page as you i think yeah before and the
thing is if you play e4 white tries to just keep
those pawns stuck in place and eventually uh fight
back but king h8 yeah and if e4 you often want to
play like knight f1 and e3 you get a nice block
eight there but i think that i think that cosius
position is uh is shaping up here knight h4 is
queen h7 okay you can just right escape that way
and if pawn takes e5 pawn takes g5 like this is
a lot yeah that looks fun although i would play
hg5 in a heartbeat as black here yeah the bishop
takes f6 at the end and you have the bishop here
this looks solid dark squares bishop d3 is
probably the move i would have played just oh wow
what's happening here bishop d3 maybe the move uh
you were talking about oh but if that knight moves
queen h5 and bishop d4 is a completely mate so
queen trove is good now i think queen h5 is good
oh man yeah that knight can't move bishop d4 is
ko so if you move what knight e4 gf3 knight f6 and
hope that you can get an attack out of nowhere yep
i think 94 is the only move gotta get rid of that
bishop oh okay last game over yeah bishop d4 yep
and i wonder if rook f2 if the move is like g3 g3s
to be as precise as possible yes this is just
well this the match is over the time is up yeah
and the time is up i just noticed that now wow
that that whole bullet portion was just a flurry
robert i barely noticed it go by and as i
mentioned during the match i just wish that
the the match was tipping in the balance as we're
watching those games that's the only thing that
would have made it better because the games itself
were very exciting yeah and i like that you used
the word flurry it's snowing quite heavily in
new york city and this was a flurry of tactics
and i loved the shorter time literal portions i
mean if tonya had gotten off to a better start
this would have been even more exciting match but
despite the score i thought that we were treated
to such a wild set of games a tactical affair and
both players deserve a lot of credit and we'll be
joined by them soon with a post-match interview
right yeah yeah we'll get the the players in here
as usual for an interview so hopefully everyone
who stuck around for the match uh sticks around
for the post game it's always nice to hear the
players take the time to give us their thoughts
on the match so we'll hear both perspectives after
this we will be right back stay tuned for the
interviews
so
and welcome back everyone we are happy to be
joined by the players from today's match uh both
tanya and kocia joining myself and robert here um
i'll start with you cos here first of all congrats
uh a nice match victory and it looked like the
five-minute portion of us was like a huge reason
because the other two portions were incredibly
competitive do you know why the the five-minute
portion was so successful for you this match um i
mean thinking about the games i felt like i mean
they were they were competitive except just there
was a few games where i i think i just had like
a massive time advantage and i just felt like i
don't have to do anything now i can just wait and
wait and just wait for an opportunity um so i feel
like that was kind of the biggest thing really
and yeah tanya what do you think contributed
to that because at first you were deliberating
you're spending a lot of time do you think
you were loved a bit by the fact that it's a
five minute blitz game and usually you play
three minute or what was going on there
no i think uh costar just dominated the match and
the five minute portion especially i think he was
better on the clock he was better prepared
and even the few games that i managed to get
good positions i never had enough time to uh
to really make something out of it so i lost
out on that as well and then in these formats
it's really difficult to actually come out if
you start so badly as well but then at some
point it was like okay if i'm playing bad at
least try and play fast so i tried to do
that when we were uh in the other formats
yeah it seemed like that was a good strategy
um back to you costia the the openings that
you were choosing i mean you guys you and tanya
had some theoretical discussions it seemed like
there were a few openings there was like you know
five ten games maybe in the same line uh did you
look at any of the openings in the break because
you knew that you were getting them over and over
uh no i didn't actually because i felt like i
felt like i was doing well in the five minute
portion so i was like okay i don't have to
change anything and and then once i got to
like the three in the one minute i'm like it's
too fast for prep so whatever i'll just figure
it out um i really just try to choose positions
that i feel like you know you don't have to know
a lot of like specific moves but just kind of
playing for ideas because last year i really i
really got crushed by lawrence because i was just
trying to play like all my main openings and like
then spending a minute you know trying to figure
out okay what's the critical move here like what
do my notes say uh but i think for blitz that
just not very practical yeah that makes sense
and oh tony i have a question for you because
i'm in this boat quite often what would you
say are some of the main differences between
commentating and playing these intense matches
i mean it's it's completely different it's
uh it's a different profession actually to
be playing and not just not just commentary and
playing matches i think even playing blitz and
over the board and playing it online
just feels like two completely different
uh different formats i don't play as much online
and i think i struggle a lot with it it was
pretty similar actually last time i remember i
played levy as well and it was very difficult
uh in that match as well i think when you're doing
commentary it's a lot um the the pressure and the
stress is obviously a lot less you're trying to
break down in more theoretical and more ideas
but i think when when you're down ticking on the
clock it's really not about that it's it's just
about making moves and then you really understand
that the players who are playing these games that
you're commenting on it's so different from what
you're talking during commentary and what they're
thinking so i i think it's incomparable yeah
that's that's really good insight from tanya
who has done a lot of very professional very
high level commentary uh tanya the other thing
that's kind of interesting is we know the match
is happening quite late for you but ironically
it seemed like you were playing a lot better near
the end of the match where it got even later did
you feel like you were in some weird way waking up
like as the match was going on i think so i think
the more you get into the rhythm of it i think the
the faster you play and like i mentioned the five
minute potion went so bad that it just felt that
all right if i'm not at least uh if i'm not going